Yannis Varoufakis Bonjour !
Nous vous recevons aujourd’hui pour une chaine Youtube qui s'appelle ThinkerView
Une chaine internet, une chaine indépendante
On vous reçoit dans le cadre de vos connaissances en finance
Je vais m'exprimer en français et en anglais Pour la traduction
et ma communauté traduira par la suite,
nous avons un traducteur pour les questions difficiles
Alors, Comment ça va aujourd'hui ?
Très bien ! J'ai bien dormi sur Paris et je suis très content de vous dire que le temps
est bien meilleur à Paris qu'à Athènes quand j'en suis parti hier.
Avez vous peur de ce qui se passe en Europe en ce moment ?
Terrifié!
Pourquoi ?
Nous vivons une version post-moderne des années 1930
Notre génération a connu son moment 1929 en 2008
Et j'ai peur que l'histoire se répète.
De façon grotesque, mais également de manière assez fidèle.
Le système monétaire,
surtout en Europe,
qui a été conçu comme l'étalon or des années 1920,
a commencé à se déconstruire.
Les autorités ont poursuivi leurs affaires comme si de rien n'était.
Plus leurs politiques échouaient,
Plus elles devenaient autoritaires pour les imposer,
en déplaçant les pertes du secteur bancaire, qui avait créé ces pertes et la crise,
sur les épaules des citoyens les plus fragiles.
En commençant par la Grèce, l'Irlande, le Portugal,
et à terme la France et l'Allemagne.
Le résultat de cette crise déflationniste qui a été créée,
comme au début des années 1930,
fut l'ascension de monstres politiques.
Salvini est une réplique exacte de Mussolini.
Une réplique exacte de Mussolini
Le même discours,
les mêmes promesses.
"Je vous rendrai de nouveau fiers d'être italiens."
La même,
diabolisation des Roms,
des étrangers, des gens de couleur, de l'Europe, de "l'establishment",
dans l'intérêt du pouvoir pour rendre l'establishment plus fort.
Nous refaisons la même expérience aujourd'hui.
La raison pour laquelle on a créé le "Mouvement pour la démocratie en Europe" [DIEM], en 2016,
la raison pour laquelle je suis entré en politique après ma vie universitaire,
était précisément parce qu'on pouvait voir que c'était exactement ce qui allait se passer, après 2008.
Alors, oui, je suis terrifié.
Comment expliquez vous que nos politiciens ne mettent pas en place de contre-mesures
pour chasser le fascisme ou l’extrémisme?
Parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas, parce qu'ils ont le système financier derrière eux ?
ils... ils...
A mon avis, je crois qu'ils ne l'ont pas vu arriver.
De la même façon que les politiciens...
Prenez Sarkozy et les siens, Lagarde, etc.
Ils ne pouvaient imaginer la faillite de la Société Générale,
ils ne pouvaient imaginer la faillite de BNP Paribas.
Merkel ne pouvait imaginer que la Deutsche Bank fasse faillite.
ils ne l'ont pas vu venir.
En Amérique, Hank Paulson, l'ancien président de Goldman Sachs,
le Président George W. Bush, à l'époque, en 2007,
ils étaient incapables de voir, ils ne pouvaient pas croire
que ce merveilleux édifice,
vous savez, Lehman Brothers,
de la financiarisation
— ce que Ben Bernanke lui même, l'ancien président de la "FED"
avait appelé la "Grande Modération" —
ils étaient incapables de s'apercevoir qu'elle n'était pas modérée.
Que c'était une architecture complètement déséquilibrée,
qui allait s'effondrer.
Donc ils n'ont pas pu voir l'effondrement venir. Lorsque l'effondrement....
...  Je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous !
Vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi ?
... Pourquoi dites vous...
Ils ne l'ont pas vu venir. Ils n'avaient aucune idée de ce qui se passait.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils ont cru à leur propre propagande !
Vous voyez, en tant qu'économiste, pendant les années 90,
j'ai passé des heures à me disputer avec des collègues économistes
qui pensaient... qui proclamaient la fin du risque.
Ils proclamaient alors — peut-être vous rappelez-vous ce terme ? — le "risque sans risque".
Parce qu'ils croyaient qu'avec la financiarisation,
la création de cette ingénierie financière sur des modèles de produits dérivés,
ils découpaient le risque en tout petits morceaux — les CDO, Collaterized Debt Obligations (les obligations adossées à de la dette)...
... Les subprimes !
Donc, ils le découpaient en tout petits morceaux et le dispersaient dans le monde entier.
Ce qui signifiait que personne ne détenait trop de dette dans un même groupement,
ou alors ils détenaient beaucoup de dette,
mais chacun de ces morceaux correspondait à différentes personnes et différentes obligations.
Certaines étaient privées, certaines étaient publiques, quelques-unes étaient grecques, d'autres japonaises ou françaises.
Alors ils pensaient qu'ils avaient créé un modèle financier capitaliste parfaitement équilibré
qui était au-dessus des cycles expansion-récession.
Rappelez-vous de Gordon Brown — une personne très intelligente,
qui devint Premier ministre du Royaume-Uni, mais qui fut d'abord ministre des Finances —
il était travailliste, c'était un social-démocrate, un vrai social-démocrate.
Il a sorti une théorie, en tant que ministre des Finances - Chancelier de l’Échiquier, en  Grande-Bretagne -
selon laquelle nous entrons désormais dans une période où il n'y aura plus jamais de crises.
La fin des cycles expansion-récession.
Ils croyaient donc vraiment à ça.
Vous m'avez dit que vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec moi, mais vous ne devriez pas.
Parce que les dirigeants de Lehman Brothers - P-DG, DF... comité de direction -
n'auraient jamais pu imaginer la faillite de Lehman Brothers. Jamais
Les dirigeants d'American Insurance Group [AIG] étaient absolument incapables de voir cela venir.
Vous savez, le PDG de Barclays Bank ou de la Société Générale n'auraient jamais pu voir cela venir,
Parce qu'ils gagnaient tellement d'argent.
Et ils ont présumé qu'ils étaient sur un tapis roulant, et que c'était simplement comme ça.
Maintenant, les politiciens au pouvoir à partir des années 90
étaient en poste parce qu'ils étaient les portes-voix politiques de cette histoire de  "risque sans risque".
Je me souviens même d'un ancien communiste,
Massimo D'Alema, qui était Premier ministre de l'Italie.
Il a évolué à travers le Parti Communiste italien.
Je me souviens qu'il avait fait une déclaration en 1996, alors qu'il avait visité New-York,
qu'il avait vu comment fonctionnait Wall Street, il était revenu en disant :
"Vous savez je suis communiste, enfin j'ai été communiste toute ma vie, mais je dois dire
que j'ai vu comment fonctionne le capitalisme maintenant,
et il a désormais dépassé les crises."
Donc, le personnel politique, dont le financement des campagnes était apporté par les banquiers,
avait cru l'histoire des banquiers.
Ma profession, les économistes universitaires, ceux du courant dominant, pas nous tous, mais ceux du courant dominant,
avaient complètement adopté cette vision d'un "équilibre général".
c'est le terme qu'ils utilisaient !
Par conséquent, celui qui disait que tout ceci est complètement déséquilibré, dans un état de déséquilibre précaire,
était pris pour un vieux gaucho qui refusait de comprendre qu'on avait maintenant un "nouveau paradigme".
C'était une autre expression qu'ils utilisaient.
Donc, vous me demandez — pour revenir à votre question d'origine —
"Pourquoi ne peuvent-ils rien faire
à propos du fascisme ?"
Eh bien, parce qu'avant la crise, ils ne pouvaient pas voir la crise venir,
Et quand elle est arrivée, ils ont paniqué.
Complètement paniqué.
Et ils ont agi comme des pompiers en état de panique.
Ils pensent qu'il vont être consumés par les flammes.
Donc ils attaquent les flammes, pas l'épicentre de l'incendie.
Par exemple :
Quand la Grèce a fait faillite — l'Etat grec a fait faillite en 2010 —
qu'ont-ils fait ?
Ils ont passé des heures et des heures...
à essayer de trouver différentes façons de...
donner de l'argent au trésor grec pour qu'il puisse à son tour payer les banques françaises et allemandes...
pour "reboucher les trous" des banques françaises et allemandes.
Et que se passera-t-il avec la dette grecque ?
"Nous verrons ça plus tard. Nous nous en occuperons à un moment ou à un autre !"
Par conséquent, ils ont menti aux parlementaires du Bundestag,
dans votre Assemblée nationale, ici.
Ils ont dit: "C'est la solidarité avec la Grèce, nous récupérerons l'argent".
Mais ce que c'était, c'était un plan de sauvetage pour la Société Générale et la Finanz Bank.
Donc ils ont créé un immense problème, mais ils l'ont repoussé dans le futur.
...Ils l'ont mis sous le tapis...
Oui, c'est ce qu'ils ont fait, comme des enfants stupides.
Ils cassent un vase et cachent les morceaux sous le tapis en pensant que le problème a disparu.
Donc... OK...
La priorité numéro un, lorsque la crise qu'ils pensaient ne jamais voir venir s'est produite,
fut de combler les trous du système bancaire qui les finançait.
Qui finançait leurs partis politiques, leurs gouvernements,
qui finançait même, ce qui est assez humain, assez acceptable socialement,
comme, par exemple, Gordon Brown, que j'ai mentionné plus tôt,
finançait le service national de santé,
avec les taxes de la City.
Il y avait donc un pacte faustien passé avec les sociaux-démocrates au pouvoir, à l'époque en Grande-Bretagne
— mais aussi en Allemagne et ailleurs, et ici.
Ce pacte faustien disait : "Nous fermons les yeux,
laissons les banques faire ce qu'elles veulent
parce qu'elles savent comment gérer le risque,
— c'est sans risque, après tout —
et nous prenons quelques miettes de leurs immenses profits
pour financer des hôpitaux.
Mais au moment où... vous savez...
toutes ces banques ont fait faillite,
toutes les banques sans exception en Europe ont fait faillite, en 2008, en 2009, en 2010...
... Pourquoi n'instaure-t-on pas un Glass-Steagall Act juste après ça?
Quoi?
Le Glass-Steagall Act. Vous savez ce qu'est le Glass-Steagall Act?
Evidemment que je sais ce qu'est le Glass-Steagall Act !
Parce que, vous savez, ils étaient au pouvoir parce qu'ils avaient supprimé le Glass-Steagall Act.
Ils étaient en poste parce qu'ils représentaient le secteur financier.
Et lorsque le secteur financier s'est cassé la figure,
ils ont manqué, avant tout, de capacité analytique pour comprendre ce qui était arrivé,
et se confronter à cette connaissance analytique.
Vous savez, Roosevelt, en 1933,
savait ce qu'il s'était passé... en 1929
Il avait été élu afin d'affronter les banquiers.
Il avait dit, en particulier lors de la campagne présidentielle de 1936,
"les banquiers me haïssent, et je considère que leur haine est une marque d'honneur pour moi".
Sarkozy, Lagarde, Schröder, Gordon Brown, Papandreou en Grèce,
ils étaient financés par ces gens-là.
Ils avaient cru que le secteur bancaire était sûr.
Donc quand ça s'est effondré et que le téléphone a sonné,
Et qu'on leur a dit : "vous savez, M. le Premier ministre, M. le Président, Mme la Chancelière,
les distributeurs automatiques vont cesser de fonctionner aujourd'hui,
à moins d'injecter 600 milliards d'euros, en Allemagne,
200 milliards d'euros, ici, en France,
à moins que nous ne donnions de l'argent à l'Etat grec afin qu'il le donne à nos banques."
A ce moment-là, ces personnes, qui ne comprenaient pas ce qu'il s'était passé,
paniquaient.
Et ils ont dit "OK, nous allons combler ces trous,
parce que nous ne pouvons pas laisser les distributeurs de billets s'arrêter !"
Alors ils ont fait en sorte que les distributeurs continuent de fonctionner, à tout prix!
Mais "à tout prix" signifiait : le socialisme pour les banquiers,
et l'austérité pour tous les autres.
Et lorsqu'on créé cette sorte d'austérité généralisée,
au milieu de la pire crise depuis 1929,
ce que l'on créé sont les conditions économiques pour la naissance ou la renaissance du fascisme.
Et ensuite, vous ne pouvez plus arrêter les fascistes,
parce que vous les avez engendrés,
ils sont comme vos enfants.
Même si vous ne les aimez pas, même si vous voulez les tuer,
vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas le faire.
Donc... et aussi...
Il y a eu de la naïveté :
"Ce sont des marginaux,
Aube Dorée en Grèce, que feraient-ils ?"
"Le Pen ? Elle ne sera jamais élue."
Peut-être qu'elle ne le sera pas.
Mais Le Pen n'a pas besoin d'être élue.
Elle a empoisonné la politique française, sans être élue.
Elle a poussé François Hollande
à faire passer une législation dans votre Assemblée nationale
qui est raciste.
Elle n'a pas besoin d'accéder à l'Elysée
pour être au pouvoir.
Les fascistes sont au pouvoir même s'ils n'accèdent pas aux gouvernements.
Et ceux qui... et qu'arrive-t-il aux Hollande du monde? Aux Merkel du monde?
Ils disparaissent comme Hindenburg, dans les années 1930.
Ils sont balayés.
La république de Weimar, ils avaient le sentiment de contrôler la situation.
Ils pensait : "Ah ! Hitler, nous pouvons le contrôler... même l'utiliser".
Non !
On ne peut pas... domestiquer la Bête.
Ou laisser éclore les œufs du serpent, en espérant ensuite les contrôler.
... Laissez-moi vous interrompre...
... Excusez mon accent français, je vais prendre mon accent français...
Excusez mon accent grec !
Non, non ! On l'adore !
Ne pensez-vous pas que notre parti politique du centre nourrit la Bête lorsqu'ils n'écoutent pas le référendum ?
Lorsqu'ils baisent les gens avec le référendum ?
Lorsqu'ils les font revoter ?
Les gens n'oublient pas ça !
Quelle est votre opinion à propos du référendum ?
Eh bien, je crois très fermement
dans l'adoption d'un modèle suisse en Europe
Une combinaison de processus parlementaire, en particulier de processus parlementaire fédéral,
avec de très fréquentes actions de démocratie directe comme des référendums
Mais c'est une chose à laquelle nous devons être formés.
Si vous regardez le Royaume-Uni, la Grande-Bretagne,
ils ont eu seulement trois référendums
depuis le début de leur histoire
L'un a eu lieu en 1975
pour valider leur adhésion au marché commun européen,
puis ils ont eu un autre référendum pour la représentation proportionnelle, qui ne s'est pas très bien déroulé,
et ils ont eu le référendum sur le Brexit en 2016.
Lorsque vous avez un référendum tous les 10 ou 20 ans,
les citoyens ne sont pas entraînés... à...
là où les Suisses en ont un toutes les semaines
... Comment expliquez-vous que la population n'est pas entraînée à exprimer sa voix de citoyen ?
Est-ce à cause des médias ?
A cause de la politique ?
A cause du système éducatif ? A cause de quoi ?
Non, non. C'est parce que nous ne vivons pas dans des démocraties.
Nous vivons dans des oligarchies.
Tout le problème...
Vous voyez, nous faisons l'erreur de penser...
permettez-moi de m'exprimer en tant que Grec pendant un instant.
Nous faisons l'erreur de penser que notre démocratie
découle de la démocratie athénienne.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
La démocratie athénienne
elle n'a duré que quelques décennies
et elle avait des défauts, dans le sens où les femmes ne votaient pas,
les esclaves ne votaient pas, bien sûr, même les immigrés ne votaient pas.
Mais au moins, elle était très intéressante dans le sens où la majorité... du "demos"
des citoyens qui avaient le droit de vote
étaient pauvres.
C'est Aristote qui a défini la démocratie athénienne
comme un système où les pauvres gouvernent
grâce au fait qu'ils constituaient la majorité.
Et, sur la base de "l'isègoria"
qui est le droit d'être entendu
et qu'un point de vue soit jugé
sur la base du mérite, et non sur qui est la personne.
C'était une expérimentation remarquable.
Avec des défauts, mais remarquable.
Nos démocraties, la République française,
La République grecque, maintenant,
la Constitution des Etats-Unis
le parlement britannique, etc.
Celles-ci descendent directement de la Magna Carta.
La Magna Carta n'était pas une question de démocratie
mais du droit des barons et des seigneurs à conserver leurs butins,
sans qu'ils soient prélevés par le Roi.
Donc effectivement, nous... nos oligarchies sont une extension - c'est comme ça que je le comprends -
sont une extension du droit des barons, qu'ils soient de la noblesse terrienne,
ou aujourd'hui, des industriels, des banquiers, etc.
de conserver leur argent
de conserver leurs privilèges
dans une association avec l'Etat
avec le peuple qui fournit, à travers un processus de consultation, de consultation irrégulière
la légitimité démocratique pour l'oligarchie.
Si vous lisez les "Federal Papers" sur lesquels est basée la Constitution américaine -
qui forment un très beau texte - c'est un très beau texte que la Constitution américaine !
Lisez-la et vous ressentirez... je me sens exalté en tant que démocrate.
... Ils peuvent se débarrasser de leur dette...
Les "Federal Papers" qui expliquent toute la question.
Tout l'enjeu est d'empêcher le "demos" de gouverner.
Et de la façon de leur donner le sentiment que tous les quatre ans ils sont consultés, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais, bien sûr, ils ne gouvernent pas.
L'équilibre des pouvoirs.
Donc, nos démocraties - vous disiez comment se fait-il que les gens ne soient pas entraînés?
Pourquoi ne sommes-nous pas formés à la démocratie?
Parce que nous vivons dans un système dont l'objectif est de maintenir le "demos" à l'écart de la démocratie.
Et donner au "demos" le sentiment d'être consulté, d'avoir le pouvoir, alors qu'il ne l'a pas.
Et en particulier avec l'Union européenne.
Si vous observez l'Union européenne, la construction de l'Union européenne.
L'Union européenne a été créée comme un cartel de grosses entreprises et de gros intérêts.
Dont l'objectif était de maintenir même les parlements nationaux avec des processus limités de consultation, à l'écart de toute prise de décision sérieuse.
Donc, Bruxelles n'est pas... ne souffre pas de déficit démocratique...
C'est comme dire que la lune souffre d'un déficit d'oxygène.
Il n'y a pas de déficit d'oxygène sur la lune.
Il n'y a pas d'oxygène.
De la même manière, il n'y a pas du tout de démocratie à Bruxelles.
Et il n'est pas prévu qu'il y en ait !
Le parlement européen est là pour apporter une couverture
pour le fait que tous... les cartels opèrent dans les intérêts des grosses entreprises.
Donc, nous devons continuer de nous battre, pour repousser cette frontière,
afin d'obtenir de petites victoires opportunes pour le "demos",
afin que le "demos" puisse être réinséré dans nos démocraties.
Et les référendums sont un exemple de ce type.
Regardez l'Irlande, par exemple. Vous vous souvenez du Traité de Lisbonne ?
...
Ils ont demandé aux Irlandais de voter et ils ont dit "non".
Donc ils leur ont demandé de revoter.
Et ils ont continué à leur demander de voter jusqu'à ce qu'ils donnent la bonne réponse.
Vous vous souvenez de notre référendum en Grèce, le 5 juillet 2015 ?
Malheureusement, mon ami et Premier ministre
...Tsipras ?
Tsipras !
a demandé au peuple de voter, en espérant qu'il vote contre nous.
Afin qu'il légitime sa capitulation.
Ils n'ont pas voté contre nous nous, ils ont voté en notre faveur.
Alors, qu'a-t-il fait ce soir-là?
Il a capitulé quand même !
Et il a complètement retourné le verdict populaire.
Donc, lorsque vous avez des incidents comme le référendum irlandais, le référendum grec,
ce avec quoi vous vous retrouvez est... du cynisme.
... Vous nourrissez la Bête !
Vous nourrissez la Bête. Puis vous permettez à Salvini et Le Pen de se présenter comme
les champions de la démocratie.
Et cela est une défaite majeure pour la démocratie.
... Donc vous venez juste de m'expliquer que l'Union européenne est un cartel, une mafia...
Vous souvenez-vous du premier nom de l'Union européenne ?
... Le premier nom du président de l'Union européenne ?
Non. Le premier nom. Comment appelait-on l'Union européenne avant qu'elle s'appelle ainsi ?
... L'union des six, non?..
Elle s'appelait la Communauté européenne du charbon et de l'acier.
... Exactement...
C'est un cartel !
Comme l'OPEP. L'OPEP est un cartel pour le pétrole.
... Pétrole...
La communauté européenne était un cartel pour le charbon et l'acier.
Puis, après cela, ils ont fait entrer les constructeurs automobile.
Après cela, ils ont fait entrer les  agriculteurs français,
les grosses exploitations agricoles intensives françaises à travers la Politique Agricole Commune.
Tout cela était un cartel en expansion.
Et qui avait besoin du libre échange et d'une monnaie commune pour fonctionner.
Comme l'OPEP a besoin d'une monnaie commune qui est le dollar dans le cas du pétrole.
Et elle a besoin du libre échange pétrolier afin de l'exploiter et de fonctionner.
C'est ainsi que l'on a construit l'Union européenne. Je ne le critique pas.
Peut-être que c'était une bonne idée.
Peut-être que Schuman et Monnet et tous ces gens-là avaient raison
et que c'était la seule façon de stopper la guerre.
Mais soyons honnêtes entre nous : nous n'avons pas créé "une Union européenne de peuples européens".
Nous avons créé une Union européenne de fabricants automobile, de producteurs d'acier,
d'agriculture industrielle,
d'activités bancaires, OK?
Et ensuite nous avons créé un parlement, européen
qui est le seul parlement de l'histoire mondiale qui n'a pas le droit de légiférer,
afin de légitimer tout ça.
Maintenant, je ne suis pas contre l'Union européenne.
...Vous voulez rester dedans ?
Oui, absolument
... Vous voulez rester dans ce cartel ?
Ah ! C'est là où je ne suis pas d'accord avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon et d'autres camarades à gauche.
Parce que, vous savez...
... Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut rester dans l'Union européenne....
Eh bien ! Pas la dernière fois que j'ai discuté avec lui.
... C'était quand ?
Ah ! Il y a des années, en 2015.
Mais il est bien connu que DIEM25, notre mouvement, et des éléments de la gauche
qui entrent dans la catégorie du Lexit, l'exit de gauche...
Mais c'est un argument légitime.
Je pense que nous devrions avoir une discussion franche et ouverte en tant que camarades.
C'est un argument légitime.
L'argument est que cette Union européenne est nulle.
Elle est horrible, elle est intolérante, c'est un cartel de grosses entreprises,
donc désintégrons-la et construisons le socialisme démocratique dans nos propres pays.
C'est un argument.
Je ne suis absolument pas d'accord avec ça.
Parce que si... quelle que soit les critiques que nous pouvons formuler sur cette zone exempte de démocratie qu'est l'Union européenne
sa désintégration — c'est la position de DIEM25, ma position —
sa désintégration ne bénéficiera qu'aux fascistes.
... Avez-vous créé ce parti politique seulement pour sauver la Grèce ?
Ou pour changer l'Europe de l'intérieur ?
Le fait que nous ayons inauguré DIEM25 au théâtre Volksbühne à Berlin répond à la question.
C'est un mouvement paneuropéen
Notre ligne, en tant que Grecs en Grèce, est que la Grèce va continuer d'asphyxier
tant que l'Europe se désintègre.
Et que l'Europe se désintégrera
tant que des pays comme la Grèce, la France, le sud de la France, l'ouest de la France, l'est de la France se désintègrent.
Il n'y a pas de solution au niveau des Etats-nations
Et ceux qui prônent des solutions au niveau des Etats-nations ont peut-être de bonnes intentions,
mais à la fin elles nourrissent la Bête.
Et nous devons utiliser... de nous emparer des institutions de l'Union européenne
pas de les désintégrer.
Mais de les déployer dans l'intérêt d'un programme progressiste pan-européen
Donc, laissez-moi vous donner un exemple très simple.
Prenez la Banque européenne d'investissement
La Banque européenne d'investissement, la BEI,
centralisée au Luxembourg
Si nous ne l'avions pas, nous devrions l'inventer.
La dernière chose que je veux voir est la désintégration de la Banque européenne d'investissement
Je veux que nous nous en emparions.
Et en faire le centre d'un "Green New Deal" pan-européen
qui finance la transition écologique,
les investissements dans les énergies vertes, le transport
la transition de l'industrie, la transition de l'agriculture
vers une économie verte
au rythme de 500 milliards d'euros chaque année
La Banque européenne d'investissement peut le faire.
Elle a les instruments pour le faire.
Je ne veux pas la voir se désintégrer.
Je veux que nous, les progressistes, nous en emparions.
... Bien. Je vais  vous poser une question difficile
Je vous en prie...
une diversion : pouvez-vous nous expliquer ce qu'est une fonction exponentielle ?
Une fonction exponentielle, eh bien, c'est toute fonction où le taux de croissance suit "e" à la puissance "x",
ou "e" à la puissance "alpha+bêta x".
Autrement dit, c'est un taux de croissance qui décolle à une vitesse croissante.
... Donc, c'est comme lorsque un taux monte au ciel ?
Il perce le ciel.
...Il perce le ciel... pensez-vous que c'est un système durable...
que d'avoir une croissance exponentielle des fonds monétaires dans le système financier ?
Bien sûr que non !
... Pourquoi ?
Laissez-moi pour donner un exemple de croissance exponentielle.
Parce que j'ai mentionné le 1929 de notre génération qui s'est produit en 2008
En 2001. Vous vous souvenez quand la bulle internet a éclaté ?
La nouvelle économie, le Nasdaq, etc. se sont effrondrés.
...
A ce moment-là, la FED, la Réserve fédérale,
sous Alan Greenspan, stabilisa, renfloua le capitalisme.
Cette crise ne dura pas longtemps.
Durant cette année-là, alors que cette crise était stabilisée par la Réserve fédérale
Le revenu mondial tournait autour de 55 000 milliards
Disons simplement 55, car il y a trop de zéros à compter. 55.
La taille totale des produits financiers dérivés était de 70.
OK ? Donc le revenu total était de 55. Total des produits financiers dérivés : 70.
2007 : croissance exponentielle.
OK ! Écoutez ça !
Le revenu total était remonté grâce à la mondialisation de 55 à 70.
En six ans. C'est beaucoup.
De 55 à 70.
La croissance de la taille, de la magnitude et du volume des produits financiers dérivés, de 70 à 780 !
... Trop bien !
Pour le dire crûment, la planète terre n'était pas assez grosse pour cette bulle.
Donc elle a éclaté en 2008.
Alors, non. Tous les enfants savent, lorsqu'ils sont sur la plage, qu'ils prennent du sable et qu'ils créent une montagne de sable,
que s'ils ajoutent plus de sable, à un moment ça va faire badaboum.
... Comment voyez-vous la prochaine crise ?
Vous la voyez arriver ?
Oh ! Voyez, les choses sont bien pire que ça !
Vous me demandez comment je vois la prochaine crise arriver ?
Je souhaiterais que nous puissions nous offrir le luxe de répondre à cette question.
Parce que la crise précédente n'est pas partie.
On nous dit que la crise de 2008 est partie.
Et maintenant nous nous préparons à la prochaine crise.
C'est pire. Bien pire !
La crise de 2008 empire. Elle se poursuit
Plus les mondialistes de Davos, le FMI, la Banque de France, la Bundesbank, etc...
célèbrent la fin de la crise et disent : "Non, non, la crise, bla bla bla..."
plus vous devriez savoir que la crise de 2008 s'aggrave
elle se métamorphose, elle prend différentes formes dans des endroits différents,
donc,  en Allemagne, elle prend la forme d'un très faible taux de chômage,
mais des taux intérêts négatifs qui entament les fonds de pension de la ménagère souabe
Et elle se détourne de Merkel pour soutenir Alternative für Deurschland et le racisme
En Grèce, la Grande dépression...
En France, vous avez une totale inégalité, c'est-à-dire que vous avez des parties de la France qui sont en plein boom
et d'autres régions de France qui ressemblent à la Grèce.
C'est pourquoi vous avez les Gilets jaunes.
La Chine connaît maintenant un ralentissement
à cause de l'incapacité de l'Europe à s'occuper d'une crise qui a commencé en 2008.
Et, pendant que nous avons cette crise, la prochaine va venir nous frapper,
pendant que cette crise se poursuit...
... Dans quelles proportions ?
Ecoutez !  La seule chose que nous savons est que nous ne pouvons jamais savoir quelle forme prendra la prochaine crise.
Imaginez que nous soyons assis ici, et que nous somme en 1982.
Et nous sommes d'accord sur le fait que l'Union soviétique a dépassé sa date de péremption.
Que l'économie soviétique va s'effondrer.
Disons que nous sommes d'accord là-dessus.
Nous serions prescients et nous serions des prophètes
Serions-nous capable de prédire quelle forme prendrait cette implosion?
Non !
Il serait possible de savoir... de prédire que ce serait quelque chose comme une combinaison
de la guerre afghane, de Tchernobyl...
De l'échec de la Perestroïka, que c'est Eltsine qui va arriver au pouvoir, ce serait impossible de le savoir.
Quand et comment aura lieu la crise... Nous saurions que la crise aurait lieu...
En mathématiques, il y a  cette expression : "les non-linéarités engendrent des événements chaotiques".
C'est précisément ce que nous avons.
Si vous me mettiez un pistolet sur la tempe et que vous me demandiez de parler de fragilités particulières
au sujet du capitalisme, je pourrais en mentionner trois ou quatre.
La première se sont les CLO.
Non pas les CDO que nous avions en 2008,
mais les Collaterized Loan Obligations (des obligations adossées à l'emprunt)
qui sont des prêts de très mauvaise qualité souscrits par des entreprises
dans un environnement de taux d'intérêt nuls
Et puis il y a l’adossement et l'ingénierie financière qui les prend et les répand un peu partout.
La dernière fois que j'ai regardé, nous en avions pour environ 1500 milliards de dollars.
C'est une fragilité du système financier dont nous devrions prendre en considération.
Deuxièmement, la renationalisation de la dette publique en Europe, dans la zone euro
Nous allons précisément dans la mauvaise direction.
Par conséquent, la plupart des banques italiennes ne détiennent plus maintenant que de la dette italienne.
Les banques allemandes détiennent de la dette allemande.
Les banques françaises détiennent de la dette française
- Et de la dette grecque aussi.
Non.  Toute cette dette a déjà été placée sur vos épaules.
Sur les épaules des contribuables les plus faibles.
Ça, c'est un autre crime contre la logique.
Au moins, ça a été retiré des bilans des banques
Et a été réparti sur les épaules des contribuables les plus pauvres.
Et c'est pourquoi je suis livide à propos de ce qu'ils ont fait avec la dette grecque.
Une autre source d'instabilité, la troisième, et ensuite il y en aura une quatrième, pour compléter le tableau
La troisième concerne le fait que Trump se met la Chine à dos
à un moment où il augmente le déficit budgétaire du gouvernement fédéral des USA
qui nécessite que les investisseurs chinois l'achètent.
C'est comme si je vous contrariais en  même temps que j'ai besoin de vous pour que vous rachetiez ma dette.
Une sorte de fragilité, n'est-ce pas?
Et quatrièmement, l'IA.
L'automatisation, qui est...
... L'intelligence artificielle...
Oui.
qui renforce encore plus ce qui dans le capitalisme induit déjà naturellement les crises
... Vous parlez de l'IA qui permet le trading à haute fréquence? (High Frequency trading HFT)...
... Trading à haute fréquence....
Non non. Je parle d'automatisation. Je parle du fait que...
Prenez Apple. Apple rapatrie maintenant sa production aux Etats-Unis.
Mais si vous allez voir les usines qu'ils sont en train de créer. Premièrement, elles sont construites
par des robots, sans aucun ouvrier.
J'en ai vu une en périphérie d'Austin, au Texas.
Elle était remarquable. C'était à la fois fascinant, fantastique et effrayant.
Parce qu'il y avait là un immense site de construction avec dix ouvriers.
Dix. Dix.
Et ils étaient tous assis autour d'une table comme celle-ci avec des joysticks.
Et on pouvait voir des énormes camions, complètement automatisés, qui roulaient devant nous.
Des files de tuyaux et de circuits électriques, etc., et aucun ouvrier
Et ces usines, lorsqu'elles seront achevées fabriqueront les nouveaux ordinateurs portables Apple
sans aucun ouvrier.
Et le problème avec ces robots est qu'ils n'achètent pas d'ordinateurs portables Apple.
... Ils ne payent pas d'impôts...
Oui. Mais ils n'achètent même pas la marchandise.
Donc, qui va acheter cette marchandise ?
Les gens qui sont soumis à l'austérité ?
Le capitalisme a toujours eu cette capacité de se saboter lui-même.
A travers la surproduction. A travers sa capacité de produire beaucoup plus de marchandises
que ce que les travailleurs peuvent consommer.
Et que, comme Lénine et Rosa Luxemburg l'ont dit de façon très visionnaire,
cela crée toujours des tendances impérialistes
parce qu'il faut alors trouver des marchés à l'extérieur de son propre centre capitaliste.
Et cela crée bien sûr des problèmes géopolitiques.
Mais maintenant, c'est bien pire, parce que pour la première fois dans l'histoire du capitalisme
les nouvelles technologies créent moins d'emplois qu'elles n'en détruisent.
Pour la première fois !
Pouvons-nous parler du "dark pool". Vous savez ce qu'est un "dark pool", dans le vocabulaire financier ?
Oui.
Et pouvons-nous parler d'évasion fiscale et de paradis fiscaux ?
Bien sûr.
Et si vous avez des recommandations pour les combattre.
Eh bien, c'est vraiment la chose la plus simple du monde à faire si vous avez la volonté politique pour le faire.
... Il n'y a pas de volonté politique !
Il n'y a pas de volonté politique. Mais techniquement, cela ne pose aucun problème.
En ce moment, nous parlons de paradis fiscaux.
Savez-vous que - vous le savez, mais laissez-moi vous rappeler quelque chose que nous savons tous mais prétendons ne pas savoir -
que le président de la Commission européenne était le dirigeant du pire paradis fiscal de l'histoire mondiale
ici, au beau milieu de l'Europe.
Et M. Juncker a l'audace de regarder les Grecs et de leur dire : "Vous trichez sur vos impôts".
Quoi ?!
Vous êtes le leader des tricheurs fiscaux et de la tricherie fiscale élevée au rang d'industrie.
... d'entreprise
Bon, vous savez... Apple!
Où cachent-ils  leurs profits ? En Irlande.
Comment le font-ils ?
Sur la base de la législation de l'Union européenne.
... secrète...
Donc vous avez... les Pays-Bas et l'Irlande conspirent avec le soutien total de l'Union européenne.
Pour créer un système où Apple ne paie que 2% de ses profits.
En taxes.
Les Îles Caïman ne sont pas un problème.
Singapour n'est pas un problème.
Oui, bien sûr, ce sont des problèmes.
Mais c'est notre propre législation et le fait que nous soyons dirigés par des élites
dont le but est de créer des paradis fiscaux au centre de l'Europe. A Londres, en Irlande, au Luxembourg...
aux Pays-bas... afin de siphonner tous ces profits.
Quel est votre conseil, si je résume bien votre pensée ?
Pas de conseil.
Vous n'avez pas de conseil à donner ?
Parceque... parceque...
quand les solutions techniques sont si simples et que ce qu'il manque c'est la volonté politique...
Connaissez-vous cette magnifique expression de [George] Stigler ?
"Je ne peux pas convaincre quelqu'un dont le salaire dépend du fait de ne pas se laisser convaincre".
Donc, je ne vais pas donner de conseils à une personne qui va perdre son emploi s'il écoute mes conseils.
Que faisons-nous plutôt que de donner des conseils ? Nous créons un mouvement politique
pour nous emparer des institutions et développer la volonté politique au centre d'un gouvernement afin de mettre fin aux paradis fiscaux.
Ce n'est pas prendre vos rêves pour la réalité ? Parce que votre parti politique est si petit...
Hum...
Vous allez faire quelque chose avec votre petite maison et dire : "oui, Luxembourg, payez vos taxes" ... non ?
Selon moi, prendre ses rêves pour la réalité est de penser que l'on puisse donner un conseil à Juncker
et de voir Juncker changer le monde. Ça, c'est prendre ses rêves pour la réalité. Ça, c'est utopique.
Ce que je crois qui est bien moins utopique et très loin de prendre ses rêves pour la réalité est de
se souvenir que tous les grands changements dans le monde se produisent avec 10 personnes qui se sont
réunies, qui se sont mises en rogne et qui ont dit : "Non, nous allons changer le monde".
Et puis les dix sont devenus une centaine, et la centaine est devenue mille,  puis mille sont devenus des millions.
- Vous avez le temps pour faire en sorte que ça se produise ?
Je n'en ai aucune idée.
Ce que je sais est qu'à moins d'essayer, nous ne le découvrirons jamais.
Je suis bien d'accord.
Devons-nous envahir le Luxembourg avec notre armée ? Directement, c'est plus efficace...
Je déteste les armées et je déteste les prisons.
... ...
Mais je crois dans les mouvements sociaux.
Vous savez, DIEM25 est une petit mouvement, mais une organisation très active... au Luxembourg !
Combien de personnes ?
100 000. Pas au Luxembourg... 100 000 dans toute l'Europe. C'est le nombre de nos membres.
... Est-ce que...
Mais, sérieusement, vous m'avez demandé quelle est la solution pour changer les mentalités.
Utiliser le pouvoir des idées.
Il y a des millions de gens un peu partout, prêts, prêts à rejoindre un mouvement qui a un programme clair.
Un programme qui n'est pas nationaliste,
et qui n'est pas spécifique à un Etat-nation.
Qui est pan-européen, qui est intelligent,
qui est modéré et qui est radical en même temps.
Parce que le seul moyen d'être modéré par les temps qui courent c'est d'être radical.
Comment communiquez-vous, comment échangez-vous, comment partagez-vous avec les extrêmes ?
Ce que vous considérez comme étant des extrêmes ?
Je vais vous le dire.
Leur parlez-vous comme à des crétins, comme les médias parlent des extrêmes. Ou...
Non, non, non.
C'est un problème, cela, non?
De façon très humaniste. On n'a aucun droit de traiter les gens comme des crétins
Le grand crime des démocrates aux Etats-Unis d'Amérique est d'avoir diabolisé ceux qui ont voté Trump
Ils les regardent et leur disent : "Vous êtes des racailles, vous êtes des êtres inférieurs,
Vous ne devriez pas avoir le droit de vote.
Vous avez été des idiots. Vous avez été dupé par Vladimir Poutine et par Facebook."
C'est ce que l'on fait si, premièrement, on est misanthropique, et, deuxièmement, si on est un imbécile.
Parce que la manière la plus sûre de faire réélire Trump que de traiter ses partisans de sous-hommes.
Ce qu'il faut faire est de les écouter. Parce que la majorité des gens qui ont voté pour Trump,
la majorité des gens qui ont voté pour Trump,
en particulier dans les Etats du nord qui ont été déterminant dans sa victoire,
avaient voté pour Obama en 2008. Par conséquent, ils n'étaient pas racistes.
Par définition, il n'étaient pas racistes.
Ils n'étaient pas idiots. Mais ils étaient en colère.
Si vous voulez comprendre pourquoi les gens ont voté pour Trump, oubliez Poutine et Facebook
Et prenez en considération une simple statistique.
En 2016, pour la première fois depuis 1949,
plus de la moitié des familles en Amérique ne pouvaient s'offrir la voiture la moins coûteuse
qui est une Nissan qui coûte 14 000 dollars
Et quand je dis qu'ils ne pouvaient pas se l'offrir, je ne dis pas seulement qu'ils ne disposaient pas des 14 000 dollars pour l'acheter
ils n'étaient même pas assez solvables pour obtenir un prêt pour l'acheter.
Et aux Etats-Unis d'Amérique, si vous ne possédez pas une voiture, vous êtes mort.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre au supermarché,
vous ne pouvez pas emmener vos gosses à l'école et vous ne pouvez pas obtenir un emploi.
Parce que le travail ne sera pas au coin de la rue. Vous avez besoin d'une voiture pour vous y rendre.
Donc, Dans le sens où, pile en même temps, vous aviez des fortunes qui se faisaient,
En 2016. Jamais auparavant les 0,1% les plus riches n'avaient autant d'argent
Et... les privations. Voilà pourquoi Trump est parvenu a remporter les élections.
Et parce que Hillary Clinton, en même temps, traînait du côté de Wall Street et
faisait des promesses... de leur lâcher la bride à nouveau.
Comme ils étaient lorsque son mari était président des Etats-Unis.
Que faites-vous, lorsque vous vous retrouvez face à...
J'ai vécu aux Etats-Unis
J'ai vecu de telles expériences
J'ai eu l'occasion de me retrouver dans un bar avec quelqu'un qui était favorable à
une anarchie totale concernant les lois sur les armes.
Je me souviens avoir rencontré un routier
Qui m'a appris beaucoup de choses
Parce que, alors que ma voiture devait être réparée au milieu de nulle part, je pense que c'était en Idaho
Je partageais une bière avec ce gars en attendant que ma voiture soit réparée
Il mangeait un hamburger et m'a raconté sa vie.
Et c'était dur à entendre. Il était entrepreneur
Et il est tombé malade. Il n'avait pas d'assurance.
Il a dépensé 250 000 dollars.
Il a fini par faire faillite.
Sans assurance, il a perdu sa famille, il a divorcé.
Et il était là, à 60 ans, à conduire son camion.
Mais ce qui m'a le plus surprit, c'est qu'il s'en prenait à "Obamacare"
Il était contre la socialisation de la santé.
Et j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi : "Vous avez été détruit par l'absence d'un service national de santé.
Et vous êtes contre le service national de santé et vous êtes contre Obama ?"
Il me répondit : "oui, parce que c'était une question de fierté pour moi.
Je ne veux pas que les lois prélèvent des impôts à quiconque pour prendre soin de moi.
Ce qui me met très en colère, c'est que je n'ai pas pu assumer tout seul !"
Maintenant, si à ce moment là, vous regardez ce type et vous lui dites : "Tu es un imbécile"
"Tu es un fasciste."
"Tu es un idiot."
A ce moment là, vous êtes coupable de crime contre l'humanisme.
Et vous le perdez.
Ce que vous devez faire à ce moment là
C'est d'essayer de le raisonner
Vous devez apprendre de son expérience.
Son sens de la dignité
est important.
Si vous n'essayez pas de comprendre et de ressentir son sentiment de dignité
Trump le fera.
Alors il est de notre devoir, comme dans les années 1930.
Les gens ne sont pas devenus nazis dans les années 1930.
Non. Hitler leur a promis du travail.
Il a dit aux gens "je vais vous rendre votre dignité"
Nous, la gauche, avons échoué à rivaliser contre le discours d'Hitler.
Alors, au lieu de nous battre contre les gens qui manifestent leur colère contre nos erreurs,
nous devrions y réfléchir à deux fois.
sur la façon dont nous allons approcher ces gens.
Quelle est votre opinion sur Macron, et sur les gilets jaunes ?
Est-ce un crime contre les acquis sociaux ?
C'est quoi ?
Selon moi, les gilets jaunes sont les enfants de l'austérité.
Et les enfants de l'austérité peuvent se tromper dans leur manière d'exprimer leur colère.
Comme le font les enfants qui crient et pleurent lorsqu'ils sont traités injustement.
Mais ce ne sont pas des enfants !
Mais si, nous sommes tous des enfants.
Mais les gilets jaunes en particulier sont les enfants de l'austérité, ils sont
le produit de l'austérité.
Mais c'est une longue histoire.
... Ils sont le produit d'un dogme.
Non, ils sont le produit de l'austérité.
...L'austérité n'est-elle pas un dogme ?
Non, c'est une pratique.
C'est une pratique, c'est très concret, ce n'est pas une idée.
L'austérité est aussi une idée.
...Peut-être même une idéologie ?
Tout est idéologie. Mais
Mais les gilets jaunes n'ont pas fait ce qu'ils ont fait parce que quelqu'un est arrivé avec une idée
Ils mènent leur combat car les politiques qui étaient
développées dans le laboratoire de la morosité, qui est la Grèce.
Les politiques d'austérité qui ont d'abord été testées dans mon pays
Et développées avant d'être reprises par la même Troïka
et transplantées en Irlande, au Portugal, en Espagne et en Italie
et finalement en France.
Et aussi en Allemagne.
Ces politiques, en plein milieu de la pire crise d'investissement de l'histoire du capitalisme
C'est très important de le spécifier.
J'ai eu une discussion avec Emmanuel Macron avant qu'il ne devienne président.
C'était un sujet de désaccord entre nous.
C'est votre pote ? Non ?
Ce n'est pas mon pote. Mais lorsque j'étais au gouvernement
c'était la seule personne convenable que j'ai pu rencontrer dans le gouvernement français
Et pourquoi devrais-je m'en cacher ?
Il était intelligent et nous soutenait.
Il avait compris que ce qui se passait en Grèce était préjudiciable aux intérêts de l'Europe
et aux intérêts de la France.
Alors, il a un petit peu essayé de nous aider.
François Hollande l'a rembarré
et il a arrêté
Mais j'ai apprécié le fait qu'il ait essayé
Et que lors de nos entretiens il nous soutenait.
Mais pour revenir à la situation en France
Je vais vous dire pourquoi je suis en désaccord avec lui sur ce point
Concernant la France.
Et c'est lié à l'austérité.
Le premier pays qui a mis en pratique l'austérité
c'est l'Allemagne.
Avant 2008.
Sous Schröder.
A cette époque,
nous avions les lois de la zone euro
face à nous
Vous vous souvenez ? 2% d'inflation
3% de déficit budgétaire
60% de PIB en dettes
Et qu'à fait Schröder ?
Au moment où l'Allemagne, si vous vous souvenez bien, était considéré comme l'homme malade de l'Europe
A cause du fort taux de chomâge
Il a baissé les salaires.
Et réduit les dépenses publiques.
Au moment même où les Etats-Unis et plus particulièrement Wall Street
initiaient une augmentation massive de la financiarisation
des dépenses
Le monde devenait fou
car les dettes, et encore les dettes
Les dettes nourrissaient l'expansion
Et l'Allemagne réduisait ses salaires
Et ses secteurs plublics
A ce moment là, l'Allemagne
a gagné en compétitivité
par rapport à la France.
Et au reste de l'Europe,  de la zone euro.
Mais c'est en quelque sorte se mettre en roue libre dans une pente
Parce que quand nous avons pour objectif un taux d'inflation à 2%
C'était l'objectif sur lequel on s'était mis d'accord
La France était le seul pays qui l'atteignait
qui atteignait cet objectif.
La Grèce était à 5%, 4%, 3%
Au dessus. Même chose pour l'Italie
et l'Espagne
et l'Allemagne était à 0,8%.
Immédiatement, les entreprises françaises furent désavantagées par rapport aux entreprises allemandes.
Et voilà !
Ainsi, l'austérité pendant une période de croissance
qu'elle soit ou non alimentée par de la dette, peu importe
Mais dans une période de croissance internationale,
l'austérité dans un pays donne à celui-ci l'avantage d'être plus compétitif par rapport aux autres pays.
Donc l'austérité peut fonctionner dans une période de "non austérité"
Parce que vous volez des marchés à vos voisins. C'est ce que ça produit.
Et Emmanuel l'avait parfaitement compris.
Il était assis à côté de moi lorsqu'il a dit aux autres
Il était d'accord avec moi pour dire que le problème en Europe
était que nous jouions le jeu de la compétitivité et non de la productivité.
La productivité est un jeu grâce auquel nous pouvons tous gagner
La compétitivité est un jeu à somme nulle, où certains en ressortent gagnants et les autres perdants.
Alors quel était mon désaccord avec Macron ?
Lorsque je lui ai demandé ce qu'il allait faire s'il devenait président,
il m'a répondu que nous devions changer l'architecture de la zone euro
d'une manière avec laquelle je suis plutôt  d'accord.
Nous avons besoin d'un budget commun, d'une manière de recycler les déficits et les excédents
nous avons besoin d'une assurance chômage commune
nous avons besoin de programmes d'investissements communs
des programmes d'investissements massifs
qui prennent les excédents là où ils sont
pour les transformer en investissements écologiques
en particulier dans les régions déficitaires
Nous étions d'accord sur tout ça.
Là où je n'étais plus d'accord avec lui
C'était sur la manière avec laquelle il voulait le mettre en oeuvre
Son plan était... et il a essayé de mettre en oeuvre ce plan
... Il a échoué...
Oui, lamentablement ! Et je lui avais dit qu'il allait se planter.
Et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi je pensais qu'il allait échouer
Son idée était de passer un marché avec Merkel
Le deal était très simple
Il "germaniserait" les travailleurs français au moyen de l'austérité
Et Merkel lui donnerait un budget fédéral.
Ce que j'avais dit à Emmanuel, un an environ avant qu'il ne devienne président
"Ça ne marchera pas
Parce que si tu le fais dans cet ordre
Tu vas "germaniser" les travailleurs français
et ensuite Merkel va répondre «merci beaucoup de l'avoir fait,
mais vous n'obtiendrez rien de moi.»"
Et alors - et là c'est un gros désaccord entre nous -
Il a dit qu'il aurait au moins créé plus de compétitivité en France
Je lui ai dit que c'était faux.
Cela a fonctionné dans les années 1990 en Allemagne
parce que le reste du monde
relançait les investissements.
Dans un monde où l'investissement est à son niveau le plus bas,
par rapport à l'épargne accumulée,
dans l'histoire du capitalisme,
imposer l'austérité en France
aura pour seul effet d'affaiblir la France, et cela de manière inégale :
Différentes régions de France seront touchées de diverses manières
et tu seras le Président tenu responsable de l'explosion au sein de ton pays
et ton programme européen va échouer.
C'est exactement ce qu'il s'est passé.
Et les gilets jaunes,  tels que je le comprends, sont le résultat de cette "germanisation" des travailleurs français,
de l'austérité imposée à la  France dans un contexte d'investissement très faible.
... On va parler maintenant de l'influence des Russes aux Etats-Unis pendant l'élection de Trump.
Ou de la "non-influence" de la Russie aux Etats-Unis
Votre avis ?
Selon moi, tout ça c'est du pipeau.
Pouvez-vous me dire pourquoi ?
Les gens disent, "Poutine a changé le résultat des élections aux Etats-Unis"
Mais ce n'est pas le cas. Ce sont les gens qui ont voté pour Obama en 2008
et qui ont voté pour Trump en 2016
En fait, les gens qui ont fait en sorte que Trump remporte les élections...
... Mais les médias ont dit que les Russes avaient fait monter la colère des réacs du Sud, des "rednecks"
Ecoutez ! Vladimir Poutine est en ce moment assis sur sa chaise dorée,
à Moscou, à écouter tout ça
Et il est mort de rire.
Il est mort de rire.
Vous savez ce qu'il se dit ?
"Mais quels débiles ! Ils m'accordent tellement d'importance ! J'aimerais avoir ce pouvoir !"
Les gens disent qu'il a essayé d'influencer le vote des Américains. OK, j'ai fait la même chose.
Moi aussi, j'ai essayé d'influencer le vote américain
J'ai échoué.
Et je peux vous assurer que Poutine n'a pas réussi
Le Brexit. Ils ont fait la même chose avec le Brexit
Ils ne cessent de prétendre que c'est de l'argent russe et Facebook
qui ont fait pencher le vote au référendum en faveur du Brexit
J'ai fait campagne en Grande-Bretagne contre le Brexit.
J'ai fait 13 discours dans 13 villes
Avant le Brexit, contre le Brexit.
Je peux vous assurer que ce n'est ni Poutine, ni Facebook, ni Cambridge Analytica
C'étaient tous les défenseurs du "remain"
Des gens comme Tony Blair, David Cameron
Christine Lagarde
Wolfgang Schaüble
A chaque fois que l'un d'entre eux ouvrait sa bouche
pour menacer les Britanniques que s'ils votaient pour le Brexit ça allait être l'apocalypse
Je me disais "mon dieu, le Brexit va passer"
"Fermez-la ! Vous ne pouvez-pas juste la fermer ?"
"Si vous vous taisez, nous ferons perdre le Brexit"
A chaque fois qu'ils prévenaient les Britanniques contre le Brexit
Avec un accent allemand, ou depuis Washington D.C.
Ou même Obama qui est venu jusqu'en Grande-Bretagne
Pour expliquer aux élites britanniques qu'ils devaient voter pour rester dans l'UE
Je me disais
"Si j'étais pro-Brexit, tout ça serait du pain béni pour moi"
Parce que la dernière chose dont les Britanniques ont besoin
C'est que quelqu'un viennent leur dire
que s'ils décident de sortir, ils seront punis.
ça revient à les inciter à sortir !
Parce que, vous savez, les Britanniques ont gardé le "Blitz" en mémoire
Vous leur dites, "nous vous punirons". Ils disent, "d'accord, mais allez vous faire foutre !
Nous allons le faire quand même et vous nous punirez, et nous verrons qui va gagner à la fin."
Et aussi... Je vais vous dire pourquoi le Brexit a gagné.
A cause de la façon avec la Grèce a été traitée, en 2015.
Cela peut vous sembler tiré par les cheveux.
Mais ça ne l'est pas.
Quand on pense que le Brexit a gagné de 1,8%... 1,8% !
Bien sûr il y avait de nombreuses personnes à droite, qui se fichent complètement de la Grèce
et qui auraient de toute manière voté pour le Brexit.
Mais cette différence d'à peine 2% -
et je me souviens d'une dame âgée
une vieille socialiste, syndicaliste,
venir vers moi, dans ville qui s'appelle Doncaster,
Non, en fait, ce n'était pas à Doncaster, c'était à Leeds.
Elle est venu vers moi après un discours que j'avais donné, un discours enflammé contre le Brexit selon un point de vue socialiste
qui disaient que l'Union européenne est merdique, qu'elle est horrible, qu'elle est tout ça, mais qu'il fallait y rester
parce que nous devons la transformer, pas la désintégrer.
Mon discours standard.
Elle vient vers moi et dit : "Yanis, lorsque tu as démissionné, j'ai pleuré.
J'aime tout ce que tu dis et tout ce que tu fais
Mais je ne vais pas faire ce que tu dis, je vais voter pour le Brexit
A cause de la façon dont votre peuple a été traité
La façon dont vous avez été obligé de capituler
La façon dont on t'a traité personnellement.
Parce que nous sommes des démocrates par-dessus tout.
Et nous préférons être pauvres
plutôt que d'avoir quelqu'un à Bruxelles
qui nous dit que si nous donnons un peu plus d'argent aux pauvres
Les distributeurs de billets seront arrêtés.
par la Banque centrale européenne.
Je ne vais pas rester dans une Union européenne qui est dictatoriale et qui traite les peuples comme votre peuple
de la manière qu'elle l'a fait !"
Et je peux vous assurer qu'il y avait plein de gens qui pensaient comme ça en Grande-Bretagne.
Partout où je suis allé.
Il y avait une autre dame âgée, cette fois-là à Doncaster que j'ai mentionnée.
Et elle est venu me voir et elle a dit :
"Ton récit, selon lequel nous devrions rester dans l'Union européenne et la transformer... est fantastique
Mais, Yanis, il se trouve que tu n'es pas notre Premier ministre.
C'est David Cameron qui l'est.
David Cameron nous de voter pour rester dans l'UE
parce qu'il veut maintenir cet ordre établi corrompu ; à Londres et à Bruxelles.
Si toi ou Jeremy Corbyn était au 10, Downing Street,
alors, oui, je voterai pour rester dans l'Union européenne et pour la réformer
Mais je ne vais pas leur donner la satisfaction de voter pour rester et de le permettre de continuer leurs affaires"
Alors, c'est pourquoi le Brexit l'a emporté.
Ce n'est pas Facebook et ce n'est pas Poutine.
Pour retourner à ma question précédente :
Comment expliquez-vous que dans l'Union européenne, les médias nous ont dit qu'il y a un troll au loin en Russie
qui essaye d'interférer dans nos élections locales ?
Qu'il y a des sommes énormes qui sont dépensées dans la propagande depuis la Russie...
Parce que c'est vrai ! Ils ont fait tout cela... Mais c'est sans importance.
Vous savez, je ne crois pas que les gens soient stupides.
Je pense vraiment qu'ils ne sont pas stupides.
En Grèce, à l'été 2015,
nous avions appelé à un référendum et nous faisions campagne pour le Non
Pour le Non à l'ultimatum de la troïka.
Même si le Premier ministre voulait que le Oui l'emporte, mais au moins nous...
étions là, certains d'entre nous, faisaient campagne avec leur cœur... en faveur du Non.
Toutes les chaînes de télévision sans exception nous décrivaient - et moi en particulier -
comme le Mal incarné.
... Un agent russe...
Oh ! Non, non, non, non !
Comme le Diable ! J'étais le diable sans lien avec Poutine.
J'étais celui voulait faire sortir la Grèce de l'Union européenne...
Celui qui voulait transformer la Grèce en terre de désolation...
Il y avait même des images de moi...
- quelques jours avant le référendum, il y a eu un incendie de forêt, comme souvent en Grèce en juillet  -
et je me souviens que quelqu'un m'a montré une vidéo où la caméra filme les flammes - une image horrible
d'arbres en feu, de fumée noire... - avec une photo de moi superposée et une légende qui disait :
"Il veut détruire ce pays".
Donc si vous votez pour le Non, le pays sera décimé, ce sera l'apocalypse, nous rejoindrons le Venezuela...
... et l'Iran, et la Corée du Nord... Tout cela !  Et qu'a fait le peuple ? Il a voté pour le Non à 62% !
Je vous cite cet exemple pour vous monter à quel point les gens sont intelligents.
Il parviennent à ne pas se laisser tromper par la propagande.
Vous savez, les gens ne pas bêtes. Même si Poutine dépensait des sommes colossales,
même s'il influençait la BBC elle-même,
les gens ne se laisseraient pas guider.
Pensez à Jeremy Corbyn !
Jeremy Corbyn a été diabolisé... au-delà de tout entendement.
Avant les élections - les dernières élections générales en 2017 -
toutes les chaînes de télévision le présentaient comme un imbécile, comme quelqu'un de dangereux
comme un bon à rien, comme celui qui détruirait le parti travailliste et qui lui ferait obtenir le pire résultat électoral
de l'histoire mondiale.
Il a obtenu le meilleur résultat depuis 1945.
Donc, les gens ne sont pas si bêtes.
Je n'ai aucun doute que Poutine ait essayé d'interférer.
De la même manière que je n'ai aucun doute que les Etats-Unis ont interféré dans mon pays
comme par exemple, leur influence sur le coup d'Etat en 1967, à la suite duquel ma famille a connu la prison.
Ils étaient un peu plus efficaces que Poutine...
Ou du moins aussi efficace que l'Union soviétique quand elle a interféré en Tchécoslovaquie
Donc, nous avons vu tout ça.
Mais je ris beaucoup à cette suggestion selon laquelle Poutine aurait une influence significative
sur quelque référendum ou résultat électoral que ce soit.
Ce que Bruxelles est en train de faire est d'essayer d'expliquer l'inexplicable.
Leur propre échec. Le fait qu'ils ont perdu la Grande-Bretagne.
Enfin ! Pour l'amour du ciel ! Ils ont perdu la Grande-Bretagne !
Et pourquoi ont-ils perdu la Grande-Bretagne ?
A cause de l'épouvantable gestion économique de la crise de l'euro.
Voilà pourquoi ils ont fini par perdre la Grande-Bretagne.
Parce que si vous y pensez
à partir du moment où l'énorme crise a frappé en 2008
cette idiote de banque centrale européenne
pratiquait une contraction monétaire. Elle contractait...
Trichet !
Un français ! Le pire banquier central de toute l'histoire de l'univers !
Il augmentait les taux d'intérêt, tandis que le capital financier mondial s'effondrait
Et il l'a refait en 2011 !
Vous aviez une politique de contraction monétaire et l'austérité, au milieu d'une crise !
Alors qu'en Grande-Bretagne,  au moins, la Banque d’Angleterre faisait tourner la planche à billets comme s'il n'y avait pas de lendemain.
Et que s'est-il passé ? Un million d'Européens se ont émigrés au Royaume-Uni.
Et cela a créé des tensions dans des parties de l'Angleterre qui souffraient de leur propre austérité.
C'est ce qui explique... Et en même temps, ils ont orchestré un véritable coup d'Etat contre notre gouvernement, en 2015.
Voilà la raison qui explique pourquoi ils ont perdu la Grande-Bretagne.
Et après ils accusent Poutine. D'accord, ils doivent bien faire porter le chapeau à quelqu'un.
Poursuivons sur la guerre économique actuelle...
Quelle est votre opinion sur la Chine ?
Et quelle est votre opinion sur l'esprit prédateur de la Chine sur les actifs européens ?
Et plus particulièrement sur les actifs grecs et français
comme les aéroports ou les autres actifs de ce type... ou les ports
Encore une fois, ne croyez pas tout...
Vous me voyez venir ? Vous voyez où je veux en venir ?
Évidemment
Ne croyez pas tout ce que vous lisez
Les Chinois sont très intelligents, comparés aux Français ou comparés aux Grecs...
Je parle de l'oligarchie grecque, évidemment !
Les dirigeants chinois sont bien plus malins, plus intelligents et modérés
que les autorités américaines, l'oligarchie américaine, l'oligarchie française et l'oligarchie allemande.
J'aimerais que nos oligarchies soient aussi futées que l'oligarchie chinoise
C'est peut-être la raison pour laquelle ils ont une presse libre en Chine, non ?
Non, ils n'ont pas de presse libre en Chine, mais vous savez quoi,
nous n'avons pas non plus de presse libre en Grèce
- Et en France ?
Pfff... À vous de me le dire...
Je suis très content de parler avec un média indépendant
Et je crois que c'est ma réponse à votre question sur la France
Mais laissez moi vous parler de la Grèce
La télévision, la radio et les journaux semblent extrêmement divers dans le sens ou il y a du choix
Une seule ligne
Une seule ligne qui est complètement influencée par le fait qu'ils sont tous en faillite...
et ils doivent tous leur survie aux annonces publicitaires produites par les banques qui sont en faillite...
...lesquelles ne doivent leur survie qu'à l'argent de la Troïka
Alors bon...
Les chinois au moins sont plus honnêtes
Ils ont un Parti communiste chinois qui dicte la ligne
Ils ne font même pas semblant d'avoir une presse pluraliste comme nous le faisons ici en Europe.
Ecoutez...
Accordez-moi une petit préambule...
...pour que je ne sois pas mal compris quand je vous dirai quelle est ma réponse sur la Chine.
Je méprise la tyrannie du parti communiste.
Le fait qu'il y ait des prisonniers politiques
La façon dont les minorités ont été traitées
Le fait que si vous êtes un dissident, vous disparaissez
L'absence de presse libre
Soyons clairs, ceci est inacceptable
Nous nous battrons contre ça
Point numéro 1.
Point numéro 2 :
Nous devons faire très attention
Avant d'accuser les autres
de processus tyrannique, oligarchique et antidémocratique
Surtout les Chinois
Quand ici en Europe
La démocratie est un produit de notre imagination
Durant mon premier meeting européen, j'e l'ai écrit dans mon livre
Je me souviens...
Quel livre ?
"Conversation entre adultes"
"Conversation entre adultes", exactement
Je me souviens
J'ai eu une discussion avec Michel Sapin
Votre ministre des finances à l'époque
Où je lui ai expliqué dans les grandes lignes ce que j'allais dire pour ma première réunion de l’Eurogroupe
Et il en était très satisfait
Parce que j'allais être très modéré.
Je dirais: "Écoutez les gars...
"Je sais que vous n'aimez probablement pas le fait que je sois ici..
"mais nous avons été élus, parce que nous sommes un gouvernement de gauche...
"Vous avez un programme pour la Grèce...
"et vous insistez là-dessus...
"Et nous avons un programme complètement différent concernant la Grèce...
"Alors, asseyons-nous...
"Comparons les deux programmes...
"et ayons une conversation franche...
"sur la manière de trouve un terrain d'entente...
"Votre programme a échoué, c'est pour ça que j'ai été élu...
"Je n'ai pas été élu parce que les Grecs sont soudainement devenus de gauche...
"J'ai été élu parce que votre programme a échoué...
"Que notre programme soit peut-être idiot...
"Peut-être pensez-vous qu'il est idiot...
"Je pense qu'il comporte de bons éléments...
"Pouvons-nous avoir une discussion, s'il vous plaît, comme des adultes ? ... Asseyez-vous."
Donc, j'ai dit ça à la réunion de l'Eurogroupe, et Michel...
Michel Sapin ?
J'ai dit ça à la réunion de l'Eurogroupe et Michel était satisfait
Et il est venu dire que c'était la bonne manière de faire
Et ensuite Wolfgang Schaüble a demandé la parole
Et il a dit mot pour mot :
"Les élections ne peuvent être autorisées à changer la politique économiques en Grèce"
A ce moment-là, j'ai pris la parole et j'ai dit : "C'est une excellente nouvelle pour le Parti communiste chinois"
"Parce qu'ils pensent également que les élections ne devraient pas autoriser...
"...ne devraient pas être autorisées à changer la politique économique ou toute autre politique"
Par conséquent, avant d'être trop critiques vis-à-vis du Parti communiste chinois,
souvenons-nous du type de politique que nous avons créée en Europe
Et de ce qui est dit en votre nom, en mon nom, par nos politiciens élus, et ce qu'ils font à la fin.
Parce que la ligne de Wolfgang Schaüble prévalait.
Ce n'était pas celle de Michel Sapin. Hein ?
C'était la ligne de Schaüble qui prévalait et qui continue de prévaloir.
Donc... on est d'accord ! ... Maintenant, permettez-moi de répondre à votre question à propos de la Chine.
Les chinois ont un projet
... et leur projet est de soustraire la chine de la pauvreté
Ils ont ce projet depuis 1979 - 1980, et ils réussissent
Ils ont un business model qui a dû s'adapter ...
Sky : à quel prix ?
Eh bien ... oui, prenons ça en compte
Mais c'est un projet
Vous parlez d'effets secondaires
Vous parlez du coût (du business model)
Cependant le fait est qu'ils ont dû intégrer le projet dans le contexte de la mondialisation.
La mondialisation capitaliste
A quel point ont-ils réussi ?
Je pense qu'ils ont superbement réussi.
Je pense qu'ils ont superbement  réussi et ils l'ont fait d'une façon à nous sauver.
Ils nous ont sauvé.
Pas vous et moi personnellement
Mais... le capitalisme français
Les capitaines d'industrie et les banquiers d'ici...
devraient avoir un portrait du chef du Parti Communiste Chinois sur leur mur...
et tout les jours... dire "Merci, Merci, Merci"
Quand la crise de 2008 frappa votre système bancaire et le détruisit
Et Wall Street et la city de Londres, etc ...
Deux choses...
Ont sauvés le capitalisme
le capitalisme global
deux choses ont empéchés un désastre total
La FED
par le fait qu'elle a fait tourner la planche a billet et l'a donné aux banques françaises
et aux banques allemandes
Parce que les banques françaises et allemandes avaient des dettes
Qui étaient dominées par le dollar, et de plus d'un trillion et demi de dollars
En dollars qu'ils n'avaient pas
Et c'est la FED qui leur a donné cet argent, qui -concrêtement- leur a couvert le derrière
Pour le dire poliment
C'était un premier facteur qui a empêché ce que ces gens vont faire,
ces gens qui critiquent les chinois et les américains
d'être frappé par la pauvreté aujourd'hui
Le second facteur était la Chine
Parce que ni le gouvernement américain, ni l'UE
Avait ce qu'il fallait sur le plan politique pour stimuler la demande agrégée à l'échelle mondiale
Les européens parce qu'ils étaient dans la confusion à cause de la zone euro, des règles fiscales etc...
... de Maastricht ...
Et les États-Unis parce qu'ils n'ont pas un vrai gouvernement, ils ont quelque chose qui ressemble à un gouvernement
Il y a le Congrès contre le président, le président contre le Congrès
C'est très dur pour eux de prendre des décisions pour stimuler la demande agrégée
La FED peut opérer indépendamment
Mais avec les chinois, ils ont boosté leurs investissements
Passant de 32% (déjà très élevé) du PIB à 51%
Jamais auparavant l'investissement n'avait atteint un tel niveau.
pourquoi ont-il fait ça?
Afin de stabiliser l'économie globale
Le fait qu'on ait pas eu un effondrement total en 2008
On le doit aux chinois
Ok ? Donc souvenons nous de ça avant que nous soyons trop critiques
En particulier l'oligarchie française, elle doit être très respectueuse
des autorités chinoise.
Nous à gauche... La rue...
On peut se permettre d'être plus critique envers les chinois
qu'eux
Ceux qui sont préoccupés par leur capitaux..
Souvenez-vous, leurs capitaux existent à cause des chinois et de la FED
et non à cause de quoique ce soit qui se serait passé à Paris
Point numéro 1
Point numéro 2 :
laissez moi comparer et contraster avec ma propre expérience,
ce "comportement prédateur des chinois"
Un de leur projet pour sortir la Chine de la pauvreté
Ils ont leur plan pour la route de la soie
Pour maintenir une ligne commerciale de la Chine jusqu'au cœur de l'Europe
Et le port du Pirée en était un élément central
Quand je suis entré au gouvernement
en Janvier 2015,  j'avais déjà hérité d'un programme de la Troïka
Berlin, Paris, Francfort, Bruxelles étaient derrière
Que je devais vendre, et quand je dis "Je", je désigne le ministre des finances
Parce que j'ai du signer, le port du Pirée aux chinois pour des cacahuètes
Sans aucunes sorte de restrictions et peu importe les conditions
Mon parti était contre la moindre implications avec les chinois
avec COSCO, aucunes
Ils m'ont considéré de droite
Parce que j'ai dit "attendez 2 secondes, on doit discuter avec les chinois
des conditions qui pour rendre cette collaboration fructueuse à la fois pour les chinois et pour nous"
Et j'ai initié le dialogue avec le gouvernement chinois
et je leur ai dit
"Je ne me soucie pas du prix que vous payé pour le port
Ce n'est pas assez
mais ce n'ai pas ma priorité n°1
J'ai 3 conditions pour vous avant que je ne commence ne serait-ce qu'à discuter de la vente
Condition n°1
Que les ouvriers qui travaillent dans le port ne soit pas des sous-contracteurs
Et qu'ils aient pleinement le droit de se syndiquer,
qu'ils reçoivent le salaire minimum,
Vous ne les traitez pas comme vous les avez traités en Italie également.
Donc, vous voulez être communistes ? Soyez communistes,
mais on aura des syndicats dignes de ce nom
et vous allez vous mettre d'accord sur des standards minimum,
ce que vous faites quand Volkswagen vient à Shangai,
vous établissez des standards minimum pour Volkswagen
et je veux faire la même chose avec vous." Ils ont été d'accord.
"Deuxièmement, vous allez dépenser, si vous obtenez le port,
180 millions d'euros d'investissements en 18 mois,
d'investissement minimum, vous prenez le port, vous investissez dedans.
Pour créer de nouveaux emplois, de nouveaux équipements, les améliorer,
pour être un bon élève.
Troisièmement,
notre pays est sous le joug de créancier hargneux,
on a besoin d'un emprunt de 10 milliards
de votre gouvernement,
pour nous aider, tout au long de notre sortie de notre prison de la dette.
Et nous avons besoin que 1,5 milliards de cette somme viennent dès maintenant
parce que nous avons des pensions,
Enfin, pas des pensions, mais nous devions rembourser le FMI etc ...
Et quatrièmement, en plus de ça,
que tout devrait s'inscrire dans une stratégie de partenariat à long terme
où vous commencerez à investir dans nos trains,
parce que nous avons des trains qui datent du 19ème siècle en Grèce,
Des "parcs technologiques", vous amenez des gens ici,
pour commencer à produire des choses
plutôt que d'utiliser la Grèce comme un canal."
Ils ont été d'accord sur tout,
sur tout.
Et maintenant ?
La suite de cette histoire est tragique.
Quelqu'un a vu qu'on avait envoyé le député premier ministre à Beijing,
pour signer l'accord.
Mais ça a eu lieu, il revient, et le lendemain matin, je m'attendais à recevoir  1,5 milliards dans la trésorerie,
comme nous l'avions convenu.
Mais ça n'est pas arrivé, seulement 100 millions sont arrivés.
Et je me suis dit "Ah les salauds!, ils nous ont eu".
Puis ils ont promis qu'ils verseraient le reste de la somme 3 jours plus tard,
mais pour faire court, j'ai parlé avec les autorités,
et ils nous ont avoué ce qu'il s'est passé.
Ils ont reçu un appel de Berlin,
"Mettez fin, séance tenante, à tout accord avec les Grecs..."
"on veut d'abord une invitation?"
"... parce que nous devons négocier avec eux d'abord."
Et que s'est il passé quand j'ai démissionné ?
Après l'abandon de notre gouvernement face à la Troïka,
Berlin a ordonné à mon premier ministre
de signer l'accord d'origine qui n'avait aucune de ces conditions.
Donc dans les faits, le cœur de l'Europe
nos décisionnaires en Europe,
ont imposé au gouvernement Grec et au gouvernement Chinois
le transfert d'un actif majeur de la Grèce
aux Chinois, avec de plus mauvaises conditions pour l'Europe, mauvaises pour la Grèce,
et plus mauvaises pour les Chinois, que celles pour lesquelles les Chinois étaient prêts à accepter.
Donc, quand j'entends Macron et Merkel parler du comportement prédateur des Chinois,
je prends ça avec de gigantesques pincettes.
Oui ? Très bien.
Après ça, écoutez, le monde dans lequel on vit
est un monde où les cartels se disputent.
Vous avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé avec Alstom et Siemens
ils veulent créer un encore plus gros cartel en Europe,
Ils ont même Macron qui attaque la Commission Européenne
pour avoir évité une plus grande concentration du pouvoir des industriels et des monopoles
à l'intérieur de l'Europe
Ce sont des jeux auxquels les gens jouent
Ce sont les règles du jeu
dans cette technostructure dans laquelle nous vivons
J'ai utilisé technostructure, c'est le terme utilisé par John Kenneth Galbraith
pour remplace le mot capitalisme
Car nous ne vivons plus dans le capitalisme
Nous vivons dans une technostructure
où l'on a un système de planification central
planifié par de grands monopoles
Dans ce contexte, la manière dont les chinois se sont comportés
est bien plus modéré et bien plus appréciable
que le comportement du capital français, américain et allemand.
- Parlons maintenant des réfugiés, de murs et d'autres choses comme ça
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe en Grèce avec les réfugiés ?
êtes-vous optimistes à propos de la prochaine vague de réfugiés
de la crise économique, de la crise climatique...
Que faisons nous avec ces problèmes?
On ouvre les frontières ?
Oui !
Comme quoi ?
Laissons les venir !
Dans quelle proportion ?
Dans toutes les proportions
Nous européens, sommes coupables
Point final
Nous sommes des criminels
Nous sommes des criminels à l'échelle de la planète
et nous mentons à nous-même
Nous avons besoin de nous confronter à la réalité
et à notre moralité
Pendant 1000 ans nous avons détruit la planète
Nous avons colonisé le monde
Nous avons envoyés nos troupes
et nos colonisateurs
en Amérique Latine, en Amérique du Nord, en Amérique Centrale
en Asie, en Australie, en Nouvelle-Zélande
partout ! en Afrique
Comment j'ai pu ne pas mentionner l'Afrique !
c'était accepté, pendant un millier d'années d'être migrant
Et d'être la pire sorte de migrants
où nous avons exporté des armes,
la mort
des germes, de l'acier,
des produits chimiques
et nous prenions tout ce que nous voulions
Ce qui s'est passé, après un millier d'années
notre continent viellit
et la dynamique démographique s'est inversée
c'est seulement naturel que des gens plus jeunes viennent du monde entier, ici
Maintenant il y 2 choses que nous pouvons faire
Un mur immense
ou les laisser entrer
Il n'y a rien d'autre, tout autre alternative est stupide
Et ne marche pas
Maintenant, Le Pen, les fachistes ils veulent un grand mur
Hilary Clinton, l'autre jour, a expliqué aux européens que le seul moyen de battre Le Pen
est de construire le mur nous-même !
C'est pourquoi elle ne mérite pas d'être présidente des États-Unis
Maintenant que se passe-t-il quand vous construisez un mur ?
Tout ce qui se passe c'est que profits des trafiquants s’accroît
les morts augmentent
mais rien ne change à la fin
vous ne pouvez par arrêter la marée humaine en construisant des murs
Tout ce que vous faîtes c'est booster la misanthropie et le profit des mauvaises personnes
C'est tout ce que vous faîtes
et en plus vous produisez plus de politiques toxiques, à l'intérieur de votre pays
Car le problème est qu'à chaque fois que vous construisez un mur
La politique et la société à l'intérieur du mur, devient plus dangereuse
devient encore plus introvertie
devient encore plus renfermée
c'était un signe de force, dans les anciennes cités grecques
quand il décidaient de démolir le mur
A chaque fois que le fils d'un corinthien ou  de Thèbes
gagnait un événement olympique
Un bout du mur était démolit, pour montrer leur surcroît de confiance
C'est seulement l'Europe qui manque de confiance qui construit des murs
Tout comme pour la situation grecque
Si vous allez à Lesbos, aujourd’hui
Vous allez à Moria
Vous verrez la misanthropie de l'Europe en action
Nous gardons des gens dans les conditions d'un camps de concentration
Ils meurent, ils souffrent,
Quand une fraction, d'une portion, d'un pourcentage de ce que nous dépensons
pour les banques
aurait rendu leurs conditions vivables
Mais nous les gardons dans ces conditions déshumanisantes
volontairement
c'est volontaire
Ce n'est pas une erreur bureaucratique, ce n'est pas de la corruption
Non ! Nous les gardons en enfer volontairement
Pour qu'ils puissent envoyer un messages aux gens, en Syrie,
En Afghanistan, au Pakistan, au Nigeria, au Ghana, d'où qu'ils viennent :
"Ne venez pas"
Une Europe qui fait ça, détruit sa propre âme
Nous ne méritons pas d'exister, quand nous nous comportons comme ça
Pensez au traité EU-Turquie
ou accord, qu'Angela Merkel a négocié
en 2015
Après avoir fait venir, courageusement, 1 million de syrien, en Allemagne
et avoir pratiquement perdue son poste
dû à la dispute interne du CDU
Pensez à ce que nous avons fait
Nous avons soudoyé, le président de Turquie, Erdoghan
avec 6 milliards d'euros
Nous avons donné à un président turque de plus en plus dérangé et dictatorial
6 milliards d'euros
Pour qu'il nous autorise à violer les lois internationales sur des réfugiés
Parce que si vous êtes un réfugié, et vous atterrissez à Lesbos
Vous ne pouvez pas demander l'asile
en tant que réfugié
Vous devez être envoyé en Turquie pour le faire
Vous n'êtes jamais évalué comme un réfugié
même si vous avez été torturé
pour des raisons politiques ou autre
Ceci est une violation de la législation internationale
donc nous avons autorisé Erdoghan
de nous permettre de violer la législation internationale
en le payant pour le faire
Comment peut-on considérer cela
comme étant une politique en accord
avec l'image que les européens veulent d'eux-même ?
Donc notre position est vraiment très simple à DiEM 25
Laissons les entrer !
Nous n'avons pas de crise migratoire en Europe
Nous n'aurons jamais une crise migratoire en Europe
Nous sommes un continent gigantesque
Majoritairement un continent vide
Même de larges part de la Grèce, des vilages
l'Italie
Ici en France
En Pologne
Les gens sont partis, ils ne sont pas là
Nous avons de grands espaces,
Nous sommes la partie la plus riche du monde. Ok ?
Le problème que nous avons, c'est que nous n'avons pas d'Union Européenne !
Nous avons un problème de migrants se concentrant
sur les îles grecques, à Lampedusa, en Sicile
Parce que nous n'avons pas d'EU.
- Parlons du modèle financier
Quel est votre opinion sur le système de décroissance ?
Devons nous être dans un système de décroissance
ou devons nous être dans un système croissant
et quelle est votre opinion sur la crise énergétique et le manque de resources
Je pense qu'il est crucial que nous séparions les 2 concepts
Croissance et prospérité
la tâche de cette génération est de séparer les 2
La prospérité sans croissance physique
Nous devons arrêter la croissance physique
Nous ne pouvons pas avoir plus de voitures
sur cette planète, et notamment les gros 4x4
plus de diesel, plus d'extractions d'énergie fossile
oui  à plus d'énergie verte
Ce n'est pas du greenwashing cette sorte de novlangue ?
Non, parce que je dit ceci :
Si nous étions dans vaisseau spatial
C'est plus simple de penser à un vaisseau spatial
qui est plus confiné, afin d'argumenter
Disons que nous avons un vaisseau
et nous décidons, nos scientifiques nous disent
nos ingénieurs
que notre oxygène s'épuise
ou que nous n'avons pas assez de capacité pour
parcourir le vaisseau en scooter
Donc que faisons nous ? Nous créons des plafonds
sur le CO² et la production d'autres gaz
et en général nous introduisons des limites à la croissance physique des choses
qui sont mauvaises pour nous dans le vaisseau
et nous disons, OK, c'est fini. plus de ciment
plus de .. au delà de cette limite
et après ça, nous avons une grande discussion
sur comment nous distribuons les droits
d'utiliser le ciment
entres des usages qui se les disputeront
et c'est une discussion que nous avons besoin d'avoir
c'est la meilleure manière de le faire
mais en même temps, on peut parler de la manière d'augmenter
le niveau d'éducation de nos enfants dans ce vaisseau
Je me souviens de la 1ère fois où j'ai enseigné
à l'université de Cambridge
J'étais choqué par la pratique du tutorat
un professeur, un étudiant
c'est tout ! une classe d'un étudiant
un pour un, c'est vraiment très cher
et c'est très bien
Donc les riches veulent ce genre d'éducation,
de service éducatif pour leur enfants. Nous avons besoin de ça
Nous devrions l'avoir
Nous devrions avoir bien plus d'énergie verte
Nous devrions avoir bien plus de ressources humaines
investies dans l'éducation, le soin
des malades, des plus faibles, des plus âgés
Nous avons besoin de plus de capacité humaine et d’interaction humaine
Est-ce que le marché financier..?
En même temps que nous avons besoin que la croissance physique
soit limitée
Est-ce que le système financier est préparé
à entrer dans un mode de décroissance ?
Pas du tout. Le système financier est un amplificateur
de tout ce qui est mauvais et malade dans le monde
c'est pourquoi nous devons mettre le génie financier dans la bouteille
et fermer le bouchon dessus
Ce qui n'est pas une idée nouvelle
Car laissez moi vous rappeler
qu'en 1944, quand le système d'après guerre
financier et monétaire
a été conçu lors la conférence de Bretton woods
Franklin Roosevelt
a créé une règle sur qui pouvait être
et qui ne pouvait pas être dans cette conférence
Il y eu des centaines de pays
et une règle : aucun banquier n'était autorisé à être présent.
Donc la finance n'était pas représentée
son intérêt financier n'était pas représenté
à la conférence qui a conçu les années 50 et 60
l'âge d'or du capitalisme
Donc l'idée, que nous devons mettre le génie de la finance dans sa bouteille
n'est pas nouvelle
- Vous avez un point de vue sur Edward Snowden,
Julian Assange, la NSA
et la liberté sur internet qui est menacée par les gouvernements
Pouvons nous parler de ça ?
Je suis un ami de Julian Assange
un ami personnel de Julien Assange
ce qui ne veut pas dire que je suis d'accord avec tout
mais j'ai une très grande estime de lui
et je pense que nous lui devons tous beaucoup.
Et je pensais ça, même avant que vous en ayez entendu parler
même avant qu'il créé Wikileaks
Parce que j'ai suivi son travail
Quand j'étais jeune , j'ai été terrifié après avoir lu "1984"
Comme n'importe-qui, qui a 11-12 ans et lit "1984"
était terrifié à l'époque
parce que je pouvais voir que la croissance dans les technologies, rendait le travail de Staline très facile
Staline, Hitler, peu importe...
La surveillance allait devenir exceptionnellement simple
De sorte que n'importe quel système de gouvernement
qui a accès à une capacité de nous transformer en
des êtres complètement transparents
Pendant qu'ils demeurent opaque
sera toujours un massif...
Ça mettra fin à tout espoir de démocratie
Nous ne sommes pas en démocratie
mais ça mettra fin à tout espoir de démocratie
Et c'est ce qu'est la NSA :
La NSA peut voir tout ce que nous faisons
et n'avons aucune idée de ce qu'ils font.
Donc la 1ère fois que j'ai découvert le projet de Julian Assange
qui était ingénieux
c'était prendre la technologie de l’ennemi
de Big Brother et la transformer en un miroir gigantesque
et de le tourner vers le visage de Big Brother
Pour qu'on puisse voir ce que Big Brother est en train de faire
Pour s'assurer que Big Brother ne puisse pas dormir par peur d'être lui aussi transparent
par peur que nous puissions voir ce qu'il fait.
C'est toute la raison d'être de Wikileaks.
En utilisant des technologies incroyables, de cryptage
Pour s'assurer que personne ne puisse fermer Wikileaks
Ce grand miroir
Alors Edward Snowden, c'est un autre type de Bête/Personne
Dans le sens où Il est plus proche de mon autre grand héros : Dan Ellsberg
Les Pentagon Papers
Ce sont des gens qui faisaient partie du système qui croyaient au système
et qui tout d'un coup ont eu une épiphanie
Au contraire de Julian qui a toujours été un outsider qui essaye de s'infiltrer
Dan Ellsberg et Ed étaient à l'intérieur
Et ils ont été assez courageux pour sortir
Et nous prévenir sur ce qu'il se passait
Donc en tant que démocrates
Nous devons faire partie du projet de renversement du Status Quo
Le Status Quo où nous sommes tous transparents et le pouvoir est opaque
Nous devons renverser cela
Nous devrions tous être opaques
Et rendre le pouvoir entièrement transparent
Donc vous êtes pour conserver l’anonymat sur internet pour tout le monde ?
Bien sur, mais au delà de ça, nous devons tous être anonymes et être propriétaires de nos données
- Et à propos des discours haineux qui se propagent sur internet ?
Est-ce qu'on doit faire profil-bas ? Éduquer  les gens ? Ou autre chose ?
J'ai une position libertaire sur ces sujets-là
Vous êtes un Marxiste-libertaire ?
Oui, je suis un Marxiste-libertaire
Tout comme Karl Marx
Non, mais j'y crois vraiment !
Marx était un libertaire, c'était le seul vrai libertaire
Parce qu'un amoureux de la liberté comprends que le capitalisme la détruit
On ne peut pas être libertaire et ne pas vouloir dépasser le capitalisme
Mais en même temps si vous haïssez le capitalisme vous n’êtes pas forcément libertaire, vous pouvez être staliniste
C'est compliqué, mais pour revenir sur votre question,
Je ne crois pas à la prison ni à la police de la pensée
comme moyens de combattre le sectarisme, le racisme, ou les discours haineux.
Les "haters" vont haïr. Ce qu'il faut faire c'est leur retirer ce qui les pousse à haïr
La plupart des gens qui font ça le font parce qu'ils se sentent dépossédés
Et je veux revenir sur le conducteur de camion
Qui a voté pour Trump et contre l'Obamacare alors que cela aurait sauvé sa vie
Nous devons leur parler : il n'y a pas de substitut pour un dialogue ouvert
Vous êtes prêt à débattre avec Steve Bannon ?
Oui, je pourrais débattre avec Steve Bannon, et avec n'importe qui
Je pense que ...
Par exemple quand j'étais adolescent, une des choses les plus inspirantes que j'ai lues
c'est le discours de présentation de Dimitrov à son procès
Quand il étais inculpé par les Nazis, et condamné à mort
Regarder un nazi droit dans les yeux et lui expliquer pourquoi il s'est perdu
Et pourquoi sa position et à la fois illogique
et devrait lui faire honte
C'est notre tâche. Elle n'est pas facile
Mais il n'y a pas d'alternative à cela
- Notre communauté nous a demandé hier si vous aviez reçu des menaces
De gens ... quand vous étiez ministre des finances en Grêce
Quel type de menaces avez-vous reçu ?
Pas pendant que j'étais ministre. J'en ai reçues avant d'être ministre
Et après
Quelle sorte de menaces ?
Des menaces de mort ?
Sur ma famille : des menaces de mort sur ma famille
Oui. Et ce qui est intéressant c'est que les pires, je les ai reçues avant d'être ministre
Quand je m'occupais de mettre au jour les pratiques des banquiers grecs
Et après ?
Après ça a été... plus vulgaire
- Plus vulgaire ?
- Oui plus vulgaire.
Parce que ça venait des banquiers européens ou ...?
Oh non non, je ne sais pas de qui ça venait, c'était anonyme
Ils se sont servi d'une tactique intéressante
Je me rappelle ... elles ont été diverses, mais du point de vue des médias voilà la plus intéressante
Donc ce site avais publié un article
Sur le fait que quelqu'un s'était introduit chez moi
Un voleur qui serait entré
Pour piller mon appartement et sur comment il aurait été dissuadé par mes gardes de sécurité
Ce qui est intéressant parce que premièrement il n'y a pas eu de voleur
Et deuxièmement je n'ai pas de gardes !
Et ... je me suis dit "qu'est ce que c'est que ça ? Ces gens ont une imagination trop développée..."
ensuite, la police m'a appelé
pour me dire.... que je devrais m'inquiéter de ça
et j'ai dit : "allons, c'est idiot"
il a dit : "monsieur
vous n'avez pas lu les détails de l'article"
Donc je l'ai relu
et... j'ai vu
quelles étaient les raisons de l'inquiétude de la police :
le site mentionnait mon adresse.
Et quand je suis rentré cette nuit là,
j'ai trouvé une enveloppe
C'était écrit à la main et ça disait :
"ce n'est pas arrivé cette fois
mais maintenant tout le monde a votre adresse
et ça arrivera bientôt"
ce genre de choses
nous avons eu des moments palpitants
- Avez vous poursuivi le site internet ?
non
non, je ne leur donnerai jamais la satisfaction de les poursuivre
vous savez, les gens méchants détestent quand vous êtes bons envers eux
et j'ai été bon envers eux juste parce que cela les rends si furieux
- Avez vous quelques conseils pour combattre les infox, les soit disant infox ?
hum, et bien, continuez à travailler dans le bon sens,
continuez à avoir des discussions qui ont du sens
Avouez-vous toujours vos propres doutes
Ne présentez jamais votre argumentaire comme s'il était indiscutable
ou allant de soi
Et vivez par l'exemple
Il n'y a rien d'autre que nous puissions faire
- Nous arrivons donc à la partie de notre interview où je poserai les questions venant d'internet, de notre communauté
Donc la première question est : "qu'est ce que vous avez à dire à propos des Luxleaks"
à propos de ?
- Luxleaks, vous savez...
Ah Luxleaks, oui
un quelconque avis, à propos de... Protéger les lanceurs d'alertes ou des choses comme ça ?
Bien sûr, nous devrions avoir une législation qui protège les lanceurs d'alertes, nous n'en avons pas
Toute tentatives d'introduire ce type de législation à été contrecarrée
par les intérêts profonds de l’État
Pour maintenir l'Europe à l'état de gigantesque paradis fiscal
la façon dont toutes ces listes
et fuites
ont été ignorées
et n'ont rien changé aux pratiques,
C'est une tache sur le paysage européen
- Prochaine question, que pensez vous de la politique monétaire moderne, du neo-Chartalisme?
La théorie monétaire ? "Oui" MMT ?
Et pouvez-vous l'appliquer à l'Euro ?
Ma réponse à cette question, à laquelle je fais souvent face,
Est que les économistes de la théorie monétaire moderne (TMM), spécialement aux États-Unis sont tous des amis
Je les connais tous personnellement
Nous sommes proches
Je suis un sympathisant au TMM
malgré le fait que je n'approuve pas tout ce qu'ils disent
La TMM est très fonctionnelle, et je pense que la deuxième partie de la question montre que votre auditeur le comprend bien.
La TMM est très fonctionnelle pour le cas du dollar et des États-Unis
Parce qu'ils impriment la réserve monétaire mondiale
Et de ce qu'a prouvé Donald Trump au delà de tout doute possible :
Le déficit ne compte pas aux États-Unis
Tu peux avoir autant de dettes que tu veux
et cela ne vas pas créer une ruée vers le dollar ou quelque chose de ce type
La prémisse de base de la TMM est correcte.
Elle est que la majeure partie de la monnaie est créée par des banques privées, et non par des banques centrales
et il n'y a pas de raisons qui ferait que nous devrions présumer
que l'investissement dans les technologies vertes, dans les choses dont l'humanité à besoin,
doit nécessairement venir de la taxation
En Europe par exemple, au moment ou nous parlons,
parce qu'il y avait une question à propos de l'Euro,
il y a environ 2000 milliards d'Euros qui attend la passivement dans le système financier
Ne servant qu'à faire du mal
Avec DiEM 25, le Printemps Européen, nous proposons un programme d'investissement
qui est basé, et c'est pour cela que je mentionnais plus tôt la banque européenne d'investissement (BEI),
sur une émission à grande échelle d'obligations de la BEI pour absorber cette liquidité
et de l'utiliser comme base pour financer le Green New Deal dont nous avons besoin en Europe
Et cela est compatible avec la TMM
- Prochaine question :
Que pensez vous de l'idée de Piketty consistant à créer une nouvelle assemblée Européenne avec seulement quelques pays
C'est une très mauvaise idée
Une très mauvaise idée
Écoutez, pour commencer, Thomas Piketty à beaucoup de bonnes idées
Et ses propositions à propos de la zone euro ont évoluées
Je me souviens, avec mon collaborateur États-unien, James Galbraith,
Nous avons rédigé une réponse aux propositions de son groupe en 2011 ou 2012
Ce plan était beaucoup plus ambitieux
Il avait eu l'idée, que Macron eu plus tard, d'un budget fédéral et d'une assurance travail commune
Mais pendant que les plans de Macron sont en train d'être mis sur le côté,
Les ambitions de Piketty sont également revues à la baisse
Donc sa dernière idée est d'avoir une augmentation des taxes pour les corporations au niveau de l’État Nation
Et que cet argent soit dépensé au sein de  l’État ou l'argent à été levé
Mais avoir dans le même temps une chambre parlementaire européenne... Je ne comprend pas l'intérêt
Si c'est national, pourquoi avoir besoin d'une chambre européenne ?
Et si nous voulons sauver la zone euro et la faire évoluer en une fédération, une fédération démocratique
Pourquoi avoir moins de pays ?
Au moment ou tu commences à te débarrasser de pays comme la Grèce, Portugal ou autre
Il sera impossible de contenir l'effet domino, l'Italie sortira et si l'Italie sort, tout l'édifice est détruit.
Je ne suis pas vraiment impressionné [par ces idées]
- Prochaine question : Avez vous peur du Italyxit, du Italy Exit ?
Et bien j'ai peur d'avoir Matheo Salvini au gouvernement parce que comme je l'ai dit, c'est un copié-collé de Mussolini
Et ça c'est ma grande peur
Et permets moi de tisser ma peur plus largement dans une tapisserie de terreur
De ce qui me terrorise moi,
Je vais te dire ce qui me terrorise
C'est que Macron aime Salvini et que Salvini aime Macron
Pas en tant que personne, personnellement ils se haïssent
Mais il ont besoin l'un de l'autre.
Macron et Juncker d'un côté,
Leur argument pour demander notre soutien devient :
"Si ce n'est pas nous, c'est Salvini"
Donc Salvini est un cadeau pour Macron. L'agenda de Macron pour l'Europe est mort. C'est terminé.
Il l'a admis lui même, tout ce qu'il à proposé à la Sorbonne
Tout ça est parti, Merkel l'a tué, comme l'on fait les social-démocrates, le SPD, en Allemagne.
Et même sa propre cabale au sein de l’Élysée, s'est retiré
Donc il n'y a désormais plus d'agenda européen pour Macron
Désormais son seul argument pour continuer à demander le soutien des français est que : "si ce n'est pas lui c'est Le Pen et Salvini."
Et c'est également probablement vrai,
Ce n'est pas faux
Mais il à besoin de Salvini et Le Pen, sinon son agenda est zéro
Salvini, à besoin de Juncker et Macron imposant l'austérité, dans le but de créer la colère
et le mécontentement et les privations qui nourrissent les bêtes comme Salvini
Donc ce qui me terrorise complétement, c'est que nous vivons dans une Europe,
Où le narratif politique est monopolisé par ces complices, parce qu'ils sont complices
Ils rebondissent l'un sur l'autre
Ce sont deux meilleurs amis, dans la réalité, même si ce n'est pas le cas anthropologiquement
Cela doit être perçu comme l'ennemi de l'Europe.
Ce duo entre le soit-disant establishment libéral, qui n'est ni très bien établi, ni libéral
Ok ?
Et les Néo-fascistes
C'est pour cela que DiEM25, clame, dit, prononce
Que ces deux là
Sont un front commun pour nous
Nous sommes des Européiste qui croient, que pour sauver l'Europe
Et dans le but d'intégrer nos peuples
En une confédération Démocratique Pan-Européenne
Nous devons tout autant combattre les Macron et Juncker d'une part
Et les Salvini et Le Pen de l'autre
C'est pour cela que vous avez conclu des accords ou discuté avec Benoît Hamon?
Vous savez qui est Benoît Hamon?
C'est un de mes bons amis.
C'est un ami ?
Et nous candidatons également ensemble, il fait parti de DiEM le Printemps Européen
- Apprenez lui ce qu'est la torture par l'eau parce que il a oublié, il a oublié ce que...
Ok. Laisse moi te raconter comment nous opérons avec DiEM à travers l'Europe.
Il y a environ 1 an nous avons terminé après 2 ans de travail
Notre programme, nous l'appelons le New Deal pour l'Europe, Le New Deal Vert Européen
Nous avons lutté pour cela, nous avons vraiment travaillé très dur pour répondre à la question qu'est ce qui à besoin d'être fait à travers l'Europe
- Avec Benoît Hamon ?
- Non, non. Avec DiEM25
En ce qui concerne le déficit publique, les banques, le déficit privées, l'investissement vert, privations, la pauvreté, etc...
Et nous sommes parvenu à ce qui est, je le crois, à un document très utile, tant au niveau technique que politique, poly-sujet
Et ensuite ce que nous avons dit c'est..
Nous avons dit cela à Naples en Italie
Nous avons eu une conférence de presse et nous avons invité  des mouvements européens, de tous les pays,
Uniquement sur la base de l'auto-sélection.
Venez parlez avec nous de ce programme.
Nous pensons que ce programme doit être soumis aux européens durant l'élection du parlement européen de mai 2019
A travers l'Europe
De la Suède au Portugal, de l'Irlande à la Grèce
Pour la 1ère fois nous avons besoin d'un programme pour toute l’Europe
ça n'est jamais arrivé auparavant
Donc les différents mouvements, les différents politiciens et les différents partis,
Sont venus au parti, sont venu nous voir, pour discuter de cela.
Benoît Hamon et nos camarades de Generations en furent partie
Ils se sont auto-sélectionné, et donc ils vinrent
Avec de bonnes personnes de Pologne, le Parti Razem (Ensemble)
le parti Alternativet (L'alternative) au Danemark, qui est de fait le parti vert, est venu avec nous
Actuà (Agis) d'Espagne,
Livre (Libre) du Portugal,
Nous avons créé notre propre parti en Allemagne, appelé Démocratie en Europe
Et tout cela nous l'appelons le printemps Européen
Depuis la création, il y a 1 an, nous nous sommes réunis tout les mois pour développer notre programme : le New Deal Vert pour l'Europe
Et Benoît Hamon, Isabelle Thomas, Guillaume Balas, qui sont des députés parlementaire membre de Génération.s font parti de ce processus.
Nous n'excluons personne voulant travailler avec nous, sur la base de ce qui doit être fait
Nous voulons sortir de la politique du passé
où, tu sais, un groupe d'amis se réunissait et disait "ah candidatons ensemble
Et ensuite seulement on se grattait la tête en nous disant "quel est le programme que l'on soumet à nos électeurs ?"
Nous voulons faire l'inverse
Mettons nous d'accord sur un programme
Mettons nous d'accord sur ce qui doit être fait pour l'investissement vert, par exemple,
D'où vient l'argent, précisément
Que faisons-nous le jour suivant notre élection ?
C'est ce qui à toujours manqué à la gauche
un programme précis qui puisse exciter l'imagination de tous les citoyens,
Et pas seulement les gens habituellement intéressés.
Et tout ceux qui viennent à notre table pour discuter sont nos camarades.
Donc Benoît Hamon est l'un d'entre eux.
- Bonne chance.
Autre question venant d'internet:
Vous voulez changer l'Europe de l'intérieur, mais le parlement européen est uniquement consultatif
Donc même si vous obtenez le pouvoir  politique vous ne pourrez pas le réformer.
C'est tout à fait correct.
Le parlement européen est plus ou moins inutile
Nous ne disons pas "élisez nous au parlement européen parce que nous allons changer l'europe depuis le parlement européen"
Même si nous essayerons d'utiliser le parlement comme un forum pour le faire
Vous savez ce qui nous excite à propos de Mai 2019 ?
Ce n'est pas tant d'être au parlement européen,
bien que nous en sommes excités également,
Mais ce n'est pas le sujet principal
le sujet principal est qu'en mai
- Vous les faites les chier à fond.
Hum, bon ça..
Mais non la raison principale à notre excitation
C'est que les élections de mai vont se dérouler à travers toute l'Europe
Pour un seul corps, le parlement européen,
et nous avons l'opportunité de faire ça, ce qui est vraiment notre principale priorité,
D'être ici en France, en Pologne, au Danemark, en Grèce, au Portugal, en Italie,
au même moment, faisant campagne pour le même programme
Donc c'est le processus qui compte, dans les termes de Cavafy,
en termes homériques, c'est le voyage plus que la destination qui compte pour nous
Parce que ce que nous devons faire c'est de donner de l'espoir aux gens qui sont là,
A Lyon, ok ? A Marseille, à Patras, à Leipzig
Que nous... Que nous...
Nous voulons aller au delà de l'habituel slogan de gauche, "une autre Europe est possible"
Nous voulons montrer qu'une autre Europe est là !
Et que nous sommes cette Europe.
Nous sommes le mouvement qui à travaillé ensemble pendant 3 ans
pour parvenir à des réponses à des problèmes concrets qui enragent les gens partout
- Une autre question venant d'Internet, A propos des cryptomonnaies, crois-tu en elles ? Pour stabiliser le système
Ou tu ne crois pas aux cryptomonnaies ?
Non je ne crois pas aux cryptomonnaies
Mais je crois aux algorithmes, utilisés pour fonder les cryptomonnaies
Donc, quand le bitcoin est apparu,
parce que j'ai ce genre de passé en ... Tu sais, de formation mathématique et formation en informatique
J'ai étudié l'algorithme du blockchain et j’en étais fasciné.
Et je me souviens, en 2011 j'avais écris un article qui disait,
"c'est une solution fantastique à un problème que nous n'avons pas encore découvert"
Mais ce n'est pas une réponse à la question de quel type de monnaie voulons nous.
Mais je dois dire que même auparavant en 2012, 2013
j'avais commencé à créer un système de payement parallèle
Qu'ensuite j'ai essayé de mettre en place quand j'étais au gouvernement
Et j'ai été diabolisé pour ça
J'ai même été appelé le traître à la Nation
Pour avoir mis en avant cette proposition et essayé de la mettre en place
Parce que je crois que dans la zone Euro, nos États membres devraient avoir des systèmes de payements publiques
qui passe outre les systèmes bancaires
ce qui créerait, basé sur notre système de taxation...
Outrepasser SWIFT (NDT: Codes BIC) où à travers le système bancaire ?
A travers tous.
A travers tous ?
Le design est basé sur celui du site des impôts
Donc ici en France, vous avez le numéro de contribuable
Vous allez sur un site et vous transférez l'argent d'un compte bancaire privé
A votre dossier affilié à votre numéro de contribuable quand vous devez payer des impôts
Et si toi tu ne le fais pas, ton comptable le fait.
Mais c'est un système en place
Ce que je pense que nous devons faire
Et j'ai ressenti cela il y a longtemps
C'est de créer un compte réserve pour chaque dossier de contribuable
Et il y aurait donc deux façon pour y envoyer de l'argent
la première est si un État te dois de l'argent, ils peuvent le mette dedans
ou tu peux transférer l'argent depuis ton compte privé et le mettre dedans,
Et tu peux te demander pourquoi tu ferais cela ?
Si l’État te donne une réduction pour payer tes impôts depuis ce compte
Et ensuite avec un code pin tu peux payer ton ami ou ton fournisseur ou ton employé
En ne transitant que par ces comptes réserves du système des impôts
Et ensuite cela peut s’améliorer,
Tu peux avoir une appli sur ton téléphone qui te permettes de faire ça
Avoir ce système que les citoyens peuvent utiliser, que les contribuables peuvent utiliser,
Qui est en dehors des systèmes financiers internationaux et globalisés
Donc le gouvernement peut créer des unités qui peuvent servir à repayer.. des Euros, à repayer des taxes
Mais cet argent ne peut pas s'échapper de France, malgré que ce soit en euros
Et j'avais prévu d'avoir... Tu vois la connexion avec les cryptomonnaies,
Que ce système soit basé sur un système en chaîne de bloc
Parce qu'il garanti l'anonymat et la décentralisation
Donc 100% transparent
Tous les citoyens verront combien d'argent il y a dans ce modèle, dans ce système
Le gouvernement ne pourra pas trop créer à partir de lui, parce que tout serait transparent
Donc je crois dans les algorithmes en chaînes de bloc
Dans les algorithmes de la technologie derrière les cryptomonnaies
Mais je pense qu'avoir une monnaie qui est en dehors d'un système démocratique est une dangereuse illusion.
- Autre question, que penses tu du revenu universel ? le revenu de base ?
DiEM25 est en faveur d'un dividende universel
Pas revenu
Quelle est la différence ? avec le revenu de base ?
- Dis m'en plus
L'idée du revenu universel est censé être financé par taxation,
Nous sommes contre cela.
Et nous sommes contre cela pour des raisons politiques comme économiques.
La raison politique est la suivante :
Prend l'exemple d'un prolétaire travaillant dur.
Il va sur le chantier toute la journée
Et en rentrant chez lui il ou elle, il regarde les infos
où il est dit que l'on introduit le revenu de base
Et que ses impôts vont servir à payer quelqu'un assis sur le canapé à regarder la télé tous les jours.
que cette personne soit riche ou pauvre
que c'est universel.
C'est clivant, cette personne ne va pas aimer ça
Tu ne pourras pas obtenir du soutien au sein de la classe ouvrière pour ça.
Mais
Jetons un coup d’œil à notre proposition, le UBD opposé au UBI, la dividende universelle de base, pas le revenu
Nos grandes entreprises sont en train de faire de plus en plus d'argent
en retour d'un capital qu'ils n'ont pas produit.
Soit provenant d'un capital produit par l’État
Comme par exemple, nous savons tous que si nous prenons n'importe quel téléphone mobile et que nous l'ouvrons
Toutes les technologies à l’intérieur ont été développées à partir d'une quelconque bourse gouvernementale
Mais le gouvernement, l’État et la société qui les financent n'obtiennent pas un centime de la vente d'un iPhone.
Point numéro 1.
Point numéro 2 :
Quand tu utilises Google Maps
La plupart des gens l'utilisent
Quand tu cherches sur un moteur de recherche, quelque chose
Ton ami ou ton ennemi.
Immédiatement, tu contribues au capital de cette entreprise
Quand tu publies quelque chose sur Facebook, sur un blog, sur Wordpress
Tu contribues au capital de cette entreprise
Mais tu n'obtiens rien des bénéfices !
Tu n'obtiens aucune part sur du capital que tu as créé !
Ok, donc de plus en plus, le capitalisme produit de façon socialiste et les profits sont privatisés
Donc ce que nous... Et c'est la conclusion.
La proposition est que n’importe quelle entreprise de plus de 300 employés
Pour obtenir l'autorisation d'opérer en Europe,
doit émettre des parts d'actions, équivalent à 10% de son capital et le mettre dans un Fond Européen d’Équité.
Et les dividendes qui s'accumulent dans ce Fond Européen d’Équité seront distribué entre tout le monde.
Sur la base que nous, en tant que société, d'une manière qu'il est impossible de quantifier entre toi et moi,
produisons ces retours, ces profits.
- quelques questions, qui a amené the BE.. BEPG Gop, gopé? Je ne sais pas ce que c'est.
BEPG ?
BEPG ou TOPE ? On aucune idée de ce que l'auditeur mentionne
Aucune idée
Ils dirigeraient à la communauté européenne, pouvons-nous les refuser... Bref, on verra cette question plus tard.
Quelle est votre opinion sur le mariage homosexuel ?
Ambivalente, laisse moi te dire pourquoi :
Je suis un vieux gauchiste
Nous avons grandis contre le mariage ! Avec la génération mai 68, nous défendions le "free love"
pas de contrat social entre des gens qui veulent avoir des relations sexuelles
ou qui ont une relation amoureuse
- As-tu déjà fumé un joint?
Oui bien sûr, qu'est ce que tu crois, que je suis un idiot complet ?
Bien sûr que j'ai fumé des joints et j'en fume encore occasionnellement
Et j'inhale !
Même si je suis pas très bon dans ce domaine, parce qu'à chaque fois que je fume je vais dormir très peu de temps après mais ça c'est une autre histoire
Je suis pas le meilleur divertissement pour mes amis
Enfin Bref, quand j'entends des homosexuels
Être extasié par le droit de se marier
Je pense: "Nous devrions nous débarrasser du mariage tous ensemble, pour les hétérosexuels également"
Mais bon, bien sûr au final je suis d'accord avec eux.
Parce que c'est une question d'égalité,
Et c'est une question de droits humains.
Dans le sens où.. tu sais, j'avais un ami qui est mort du VIH,
Et la personne qui à été complètement détruite et qui était à ses côtés toute sa vie,
a été empêché, par la famille du défunt, de se présenter aux funérailles. Sur la base du fait qu'il n'avait pas le droit.
Nous devons mettre fin à ce genre de situations. Dès maintenant.
La première partie de ma réponse est une réponse instinctive soixante-huitarde
Mais pour le ici et maintenant, nous devrions tous avoir le droit de nous marier à qui nous voulons.
Et par la suite, inventons ensemble à une société sans contrats sociaux
...
La Gestation pour Autrui [Surrogacy] ?
Oh ! Je ne supporte pas la GPA
L'idée qu'une femme, loue son utérus, dans le contexte de notre culture de l'entreprise me dégoûte.
Je ne sais pas ce que cela pourrait signifier en terme de politiques, je n'y ai pas vraiment réfléchi
Mais je dois dire que..
Écoute, nous vivons dans un monde où il y a tant d’orphelins
Il y a tant d'enfants qui crèvent d'envie d'avoir un peu d'amour, d'affection, des parents...
Qu'utiliser ton pouvoir monétaire,
pour louer l'utérus d'une femme qui est ensuite utilisée comme réceptacle.
Au lieu d'adopter un orphelin. Ça ne me semble pas correct
C'est mon instinct, je n'ai pas de politique là dessus.
- Nous arrivons à la fin de notre interview, il y a deux questions.
OK
- La première est : Donnez nous quelques livres, des conseils pour choisir des livres, quel est votre livre préféré ?
Oh bon sang, c'est une question impossible.
- Ouais ! Donnez nous en 3
Ouais et après tu me demandes mes 3 morceaux de musique préférés, et mes 3 films, je meurs, je veux dire, j'en ai aucune idée.
Ok 3...
- Pour toi les livres les plus puissants que tu ais jamais lus
Les plus quoi?
- Puissants. Les plus... inspirants
... Je vais vous en donner 3 mais ce sera aléatoire, si tu me demandes 5 min plus tard ça sera 3 différents
- Vas-y
Je préfère être clair avec ça.
Je pense que...
Ok, 3, c'est bon
1: C'est... Je pense que ça doit être...
Les pièces de Sophocles
Et spécialement la trilogie à propos d’œdipe, d'Antigone et fils
C'est crucial pour moi
En terme de ma comprehension de la résistance à l'authorité
Et aussi sur le pouvoir des prophéties, qui sont si importantes pour façonner le monde dans lequel nous vivons.
Un deuxième livre qui a été je pense
Essentiel à mon éducation, c'est...
La préface de l'"introduction à la critique économique" de Karl Marx
Spécifiquement ces 10 petites pages
C'est un impact remarquable sur ma vie.
Et ajoutons Crimes et Châtiment de Dostoïevski, pour un peu de morosité et de ténèbres
- Donc la dernière question n'est pas une question
Donnez un conseil à la nouvelle génération, quelque chose comme une bouteille à la mer
Quelque chose comme ?
- une bouteille à la mer, un message dans une bouteille.
Subvertissez le paradigme dominant.
- C'est tout ?
C'est tout.
Ne prenez jamais ce qui est présenté à vous comme autoritaire.. Subvertissez le.
Yànis Varoufàkis, merci
Merci.
Coupez.